GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO CALL
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW TO ORDER.
THE BILL ALONG DAY COLLEAGUES --
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED.
BEFORE I START WITH MY OPENING
COMMENTS LET ME JUST ANNOUNCED
NOW.
A COUPLE OF CHANGES TO THE
AGENDA.
ON THE VOTE ONLY [inaudible]
WE WILL BE PULLING TWO ITEMS.
IN TO THE POLLS FOR DISCUSSION
AND VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY TWO
JANITORIAL SERVICES A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
AND ISSUE FORTY THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT EXPANSION IN
ADVANCE PAYMENTS AGAIN THOSE WHO
SIMPLY BEING MOVED FROM VOTE
ONLY.
DOWN TO PROPOSAL FOR DISCUSSION
AND VOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF MY COLLEAGUES.
WITH THAT IN TODAY'S HEARING
WILL CONSIDER FINAL ACTIONS TO
COMPLETE THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FISCAL YEAR.
MOST OF THE ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ARE ON VOTE ONLY BECAUSE
THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY HEARD OF
SUBCOMMITTEE OR TECHNICAL OR
MINOR CHANGES.
TODAY'S AGENDA REFLECTS THE HARD
WORK OF OUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES AND I WANT TO TIP MY
HAT AND THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO PUT IN THOSE LONG
HOURS ON THURSDAYS AFTERNOON --
TO GET US WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
THERE WERE FIFTY NINE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS YEAR
AND IN ADDITION TO OVERSIGHT
WORK THE SUBCOMMITTEE THE
MEMBERS HEARD TOOK ACTION ON THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS.
AS WELL AS THE NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
THE BUDGET PACKAGE BEFORE TODAY
REFLECT THE BALANCED APPROACH TO
CRAFTING THE SENATE PLAN THAT
MAKES A BOLD INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WHILE CONTINUING
RESPONSIBLE PRACTICES OF
BUILDING RESERVES AND PAYING
DOWN DEBT I ORDER TO PROTECT
THE SAME CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
THAT ARE RESIDENTS RELY ON
DURING THE NEXT ECOOMIC
DOWNTURN.
THE SENATE'S BUDGET PLAN RELIES
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
REVENUE FORECAST BILLS IN THE
GOVERNOR STRONG MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL AND INCLUDES TOTAL
SPENDING OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND TOTAL GENERAL FUND RESERVES
OF NINETEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN ALLOCATES
AN ALMOST EIGHTY TWENTY SPLIT.
80% OF AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO
PAYING DOWN DEBT BUILDING
RESERVES AND ONE TIME SPENDING.
AND ABOUT 20% OF THE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED FOR ON
GOING INVESTMENTS.
SHORTLY ARE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
WILL GET INTO THE DETAILS OF THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE SUBCOMMITTEE THIS
YEAR.
HOWEVER SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
INCLUDE.
LARGEST RESERVES IN HISTORY OF
NINETEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION IN THE RAINY
DAY FUND ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN THE SAFETY NET RESERVE AND
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN THE
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES.
RECORD LEVELS OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES ABOUT THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT ALLOCATION INCREASE ACCESS
TO EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IMPROVED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AGING INVESTMENTS HIGHER RATES
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
IMPROVED FUNDING TO FIGHT
POVERTY. ONE TIME AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
AN ON GOING HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
PERMANENT DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
INVESTMENTS IN RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION AND RE ENTRY SUCCESS
INITIATIVES AND IMPROVED ACCESS
TO JUSTICE WELL WE KNOW THERE'S
STILL WORK TO BE DONE AND
ADDRESSING THE MULTITUDE OF
ISSUES CONFRONTING THE RESIDENTS
OF OUR STATE.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
SENATE'S BUDGET BILLS ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
PRIORITIES THAT MANY OF US IN
THE LEGISLATURE CHAIR.
WHILE THE SERVICE PLAN IS A BOLD
AND RESPONSIBLE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SHARE SIMILAR
CHARACTERISTICS.
AGAIN I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF ALL FIVE OF
THE SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
IN CONSTRUCTING THE SENATE PLAN.
I'LL ASK THE SUB CHEERS TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL REGARDING THE
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN WITHIN EACH OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE JURISDICTIONS.
INSTEAD OF OPENING COMMENT FOR
YOU SIR SENATOR NIELSEN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THIS IS A GOOD
STARTING POINT TO MOVE ON A AND
THEN TO CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
DELIBERATIONS HAVE BEEN VERY
THOROUGH THUS FAR.
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
UNRESOLVED ISSUES AND CONCERNS.
BUT WE'VE MOVED TO A GOOD SPOT
TO BEGIN OUR CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE DELIBERATIONS WERE
ALREADY TO GO AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM IN
CALL ROLE PLEASE ENTER MITCHELL
HERE ENTER NIELSEN.
BETTER ABOUT.
CENTER DRAWS SO.
SENATOR HURTADO.
CENTER JONES.
BETTER LEYVA.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING SENATOR MORE LOCK.
CENTER MORRELL.
SENATOR PAN.
FOUNDER ROSS -- UNDER SKINNER.
SENATOR STERN.
THUNDERSTONE.
FENDER AMBERG FAIR AYE KASKI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
COMMITTEE NOTES THE PRESENCE OF
A QUORUM.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED--
WITH -- REPORTS FROM
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS SUBCOMMITTEE
ONE SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
ON EDUCATION A HELD A TOTAL OF
TWELVE HEARINGS CONSIDERED
ISSUES FROM.
CHILDHOOD K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION AND BEFORE I
BRIEFED THE SPECIFICS IN LINE
WITH THE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF WE WORK
TODAY'S BUT OF COURSE THEY WORK
THE DAYS AND THE NIGHTS. TO MAKE
US TO TRY TO MAKE US LOOK SMART.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SPECIFICS WE
PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET FOR OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND IN ADDITIONAL
CHILDCARE SLOTS GENERAL AND
FEDERAL FUNDS. EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
INCREASE RATES FOR PART DAY
LICENSE EXEMPT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
WOULD BE PROVIDED FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AN ON GOING FUNDS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION BY EQUALIZING.
SPECIAL EDUCATION PER PUPIL
RATES TO THE NINETIETH
PERCENTILE IN CREATING AN EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM TO FUND
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN.
WITH DISABILITIES IN EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS WE PROVIDED
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN COUNTY.
MENTAL HEALTH OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES WE PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
OF FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS SEE ISSUE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WE INCREASED
ENROLLMENT ATC. ISSUE WHEN YOU
SEE BY TEN THOUSAND AND ONE
THOUSAND NEW RESIDENT.
UNDERGRADUATES RESPECTIVELY.
WE INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS BY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANTS AWARDS AND INCREASE THE
CAL GRANT BE AXIS AWARD.
BY ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS AND FINALLY
WE APPROVED ALL OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
THANK YOU VENTURE.
HE VERY MUCH SENATOR ROTH SUB TO
CHAIR CENTER Y. KOWSKI THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND DIES
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IN A
CHAIN.
TRANSPORTATION HAD THEIR FAIR
SHARE FLANK THE HEARINGS AT THIS
YEAR I TOO WOULD LIKE TO CALL
OUT -- MISS JOANNE REUTER MISTER
JAMES HACKER ON THE MAJORITY IN
THAT THE THE FLOATING STAFF ON
THE MINORITY IN THAT AND SUB TO
IN THE BUDGET THI YEAR FOR THE
GREAT WORK THAT THEY DID.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF TOP LINE --
NUMBERS FIRST STEP TO REMEMBER
WE DID ABOUT.
WE JUST ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE ISSUES WE HAD
NEARLY A HUNDRED MEMBERS
REQUESTS FOR A DIFFERENT FUNDING
PROJECTS AND WE APPROVED ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
SPENDING FROM THE BOND A JUST
LAST WEEK TO SUBCOMMITTEE
APPROVED A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
FOR A FUND PLANNED THE GT R. F.
PLAN REPRESENTS THE THIS
CALIFORNIA SENATE'S PRIORITIES
FOR FUNDING AND TARGETS THOSE
FUNDS IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES.
IN ADDRESS THE MAJOR CHALLENGES --
CLIMATE CHANGE POSE CLIMATE
CHANGE POSES. FOR CALIFORNIA AS
A FOLLOWING THE RULE OF LAW.
SOME FOLKS MIGHT HAVE AN NOT
KNOWN THAT THE AUCTION RESULTS
CAME IN FOR THE MAY AUCTION THEY
ARE.
A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE HIS SO IF
WE DO THE MATH ON THE 40%
SOMEWHERE AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAT'S AVAILABLE --
UNDER THE ROBOTICS ROBUST AKTION
I WILL COVER EVERY ITEM THAT --
BUT THAT WE TOOK UP BUT IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS WHEN WE HAVE WE
COMMIT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
DOLLARS FOR HEALTHY FORCE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BUILDING LONG TERM RESILIENCY
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
WASTE DIVERSION AND RECITE.
RECYCLING IN FOR STRUCTURE MUCH
OF SUB TO STEIN WAS FOCUSED
APPROPRIATELY ON THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES.
IN TERMS OF NEW FIRE WHAT.
WILDFIRE SPENDING.
THE COMMITTEE APPROVED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT NEW
POSITIONS -- WITH CAL FIRE
THIRTEEN NEW -- FIRE ENGINES
JUST.
MORE TO COME ACQUISITION OF
SEVEN SEE ONE THIRTY AIR.
TANKERS AND A LONER FOR A COUPLE
OF DAYS AS WE TEACH OUR CAN
EXTEND -- PILOTS HAD TO DRIVE
HIM AS WELL AS A SIX POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EMPLOYEES
WELLNESS GIVEN THE THE
CHALLENGES OF THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT.
EXTENDED STAY OUT IN THE THE
FIRE TWO OTHER IMPORTANT ISSUES
SOMEONE A TOUCH ON INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION WATER THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOCAL IN CAPITAL FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AND
THEIR OLD SENATE BILL ONE THE
ROAD REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT
ALSO HAS. ONE POINT NINE BILLION
FOR PROJECT DELIVERY -- WORKLOAD
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE SHOP IN THE STATE
FUNDS LASTLY EVERY CALIFORNIAN
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE.
CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER SUBCOMMITTEE.
TO APPROVED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND CONTENTION ON THE PASSAGE
OF CENTER MINING'S -- SP TWO
HUNDRED TO CREATE A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUN.
THE AMOUNT CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATED SHOPPER
REDUCES UP BY AN AMOUNT
EQUIVALENT TO ANY NEW REVENUES
ENACTED INTO LAW A TO FINANCE --
THE WATER FUN CENTER MINING HAS
BUILT A BROAD COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO HUNDRED AND
IT'S CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA.
MOVES FORWARD TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER -- TO THE IMPACT
THE IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES WHICH
CALIFORNIA HAS JURISDICTION OVER
AT LEAST THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES BOARD.
SO THOSE ARE JUST A COUPLE OF A
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE WORK DONE
BY HAS.
SEP TWENTY TWO I'D LIKE.
TO THANK MY SUBCOMMITTEE --
MEMBERS -- VICE CHAIR -- JONES
AS WELL AS CENTER MINING CENTER
MCGUIRE IN CENTER STERN FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT THEY DID IN A
SUCCESSFUL YEAR FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR --
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE THIRTY PM
MIND YOU -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND ITS FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING MY
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER TADO
ANSWER STONE FOR THE HARD WORK
AND ALSO THE STAFF ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE PARTICULARLY MY
RECOGNIZE -- THAT'S GOT --
GUESTS AND WE NEED TO POKE FOR
NOT ONLY THE LONG HOURS -- THEY
SPENT IN HERE AND I'LL TELL YOU
WE HAD HEARINGS RUN UNTIL
FREQUENTLY PAST SIX OR SEVEN PM
HERE IN THIS VERY ROOM -- SO
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS HEARINGS WILL
BE COVERED A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS AND ALSO I THINK
REPUBLICAN STAFF AS WELL -- SO
JUST TO HIT SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE THINGS -- THAT
WE COVERED.
SO -- STARTING WITH COVERED
CALIFORNIA.
THIS OF COMMUNITY ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES APPROVED -- PRICE
ME SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE SUBSIDIES FOR
THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORD HEALTH-INSURANCE ON THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET WILL BE DEBATING.
SOME OF THE MORE.
DETAILS OF THOSE -- HERE TODAY
BUT THAT THAT INCLUDES I SHOULD
POINT OUT THE HELPS OUT THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP PURCHASE
HEALTH INSURANCE AND INTO THE
PART OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
WHICH OVERSEES THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM WE APPROVED EXPANDED
ACCESS THE FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
FOR ALL THE CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG
ADULTS.
NINETEEN TO TWENTY FIVE NO OF
CALIFORNIA CEDARS SENIORS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
BUILDING ON OUR PREVIOUS EFFORTS
A PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE A FULL
SCOPE MEDICAL COVERAGE.
WE ALSO ENTERED AND DID THAT THE
SENIOR PENALTY EXPANDING ATTIC
ACCESS TO MEDICARE FOR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES UP
210038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL ENSURING THAT NO SENIOR
WILL LOSE THEIR HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE WHEN THEY TURN.
SIXTY FIVE SO CAN BE ALSO
RESTORED -- THE REMAINING
RECESSION ERA CUTS TO MEDICARE
OUT.
WHAT ARE TERMED OPTIONAL
BENEFITS BUT WE TALKING ABOUT
AUDIOLOGY INCONTINENCE CREAMS
WASHES BUT DIED JUNE SPEECH
THERAPY THEY'RE NOT OPTIONAL TO
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM?
AND THAT WILL BEGIN THE JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
APPROVED FUNDING FOR THE
RESTORATION THE OPTICAL BENEFIT.
BEGAN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH WAS PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED
BY IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACT WITH I'M SURE THAT
HAPPENS.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVED
EXTENSION OF THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX HELP PROVIDE A
STABLE FUNDING BASE FOR THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM RESULTING IN
GENERAL FUND OFFSETS OF ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THIS IS A
MECHANISM THAT DOLLY HAS TO
STAND PROGRAMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN OTHER
STATES AS WELL -- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVED THE
PACKAGE OF INVESTMENTS WITH PROP
FIFTY SIX TOBACCO TAX REVENUE
MATCH WITH FEDERAL FUNDS
INCLUDING CONTINUATION OF TWO
POINT TWO BILLION. FOR BADLY
NEEDED PROVIDER RATE INCREASES
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION
FOR VALUE BASED.
AS PROGRAM TO IMPROVE.
CERTAIN HEALTH METRICS AND MEDI
CAL PARTICULARLY -- TRYING TO
PROVE THAT CARE OF CHRONIC
CONDITIONS A HUNDRED FIVE
MILLION FOR DEVELOPMENTAL TRAUMA
SCREENINGS TO ENSURE THEIR KIDS
ARE STARTING GETTING GOOD START
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION FOR THE
POSITION AND DENNIS.
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM THE
DRAWER SO WORKFORCE ISSUES AND
FIFTY MILLION PROVIDER TRAINING --
FOR TO FOR PROBABLY DELIVERED
TRAUMA SCREEN.
AGAIN AS IMPORTANT PREVENTIVE
STEP. FOR THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENTS APPROVED A TOTAL OF
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE WE
APPROVED SIGNIFICANT NEW
RESOURCES TO FIGHT THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES INCLUDING
FORTY MILLION FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THE MEASURE DISEASE
OUTBREAKS -- TWENTY MILLION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HIV PREVENTION AND
TWENTY MILLION FOR STD
PREVENTION.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO APPROVED
TEN MILLION TO BUILD A STATEWIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
EARLY DETECTION AND TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS OF ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
HOW'S IT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT WE
ALSO MADE THE DIGITAL VESTMENTS
AN AGING TO THE PART AGING.
INCLUDING LONG TERM CARE BUT
IT'S MEN AND SENIOR.
NUTRITION PROGRAMS THE PHARMACY
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WE TOOK
MAJOR STEPS.
TO DO SURE ACCESS TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- TOOK
SEVERAL ACTIONS TOTALING MORE
THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
PROVIDES FISCAL RELIEF TO
PROVIDERS THAT SERVE THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED COMMUNITY.
THAT INCLUDES RESTORATION OF
SOCIAL RECREATION IN CAMP
SERVICES REPEALING THE HALF THE
BILLING PROCESS POLICY IN THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE WHICH
THAT SIPHON FUNDS AWAY FROM
PROVIDERS.
AND A RATE INCREASE OF AT LEAST
8% FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS TO MAKE
UP -- FOR PASSED THE CUTS AND
LACK OF INCREASES THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO DOT THE
TRAILER BILLING WHICH PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL MEASURES TO ENHANCE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN
THE DD SYSTEM.
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
APPROVED THE DID WE APPROVED AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION TO
MAINTAIN TO BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME PROGRAM.
WHICH IS REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM EXPERIENCING OUR RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND INCREASED
FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
WE ARE APPROVED THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
TO INK INCREASE TO THE COW WORKS
GRANTS.
THIS ACTUAL REYES GRANTS250% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
PERSISTENCE UNITS OF ONE AND 47%
FOR OTHER ASSISTANT UNITS
MAINTAINING THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
ENDING DEEP POVERTY FOR ALL
ASSISTED UNITS. THIRTY FAMILIES.
FIRST ONE TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET AGREEMENT SO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO PROVED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ABOVE THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL OF FORTY POINT
SIX MILLION TO EXPAND STAGE ONE
CHILD CARE. TO PROVIDE FULL TIME
CARE FOR TWELVE MONTHS UNTIL
FAMILY TRANSFERRED TO STAGE TO
CHILD CARE SO SURE STABILITY IN
CHILD CARE STAGE.
ONE THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
APPROVED THIRTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO UPDATE THE EARNED
INCOME DISREGARD THIS UPDATE IS
INTENDED TO FACILITATE ENCOURAGE
PAID EMPLOYMENT TO ALLOW PEOPLE
LOW INCOME TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY.
HAVE SOME SAVINGS -- SO THOSE
ARE JUST THE HIGHLIGHTS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
BUDGETARY.
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH US
SENATOR PAN WILL GO ON TO SUB.
FOR WELCOME NEW SUB CHAIR CENTER
THERE ALSO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ON BEHALF OF SENATORS -- BERG
AND NIELSEN I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR VERY MUCH -- FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK -- THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING
FOR THE WORK.
THE LA -- AND OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF JAMES YOUNG
THE NIDA AND JOSEPH -- THANK YOU
ALL EXTRAORDINARY HARD WORK --
WE HELD A TOTAL OF THIRTEEN
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS.
AND CONSIDERED ISSUES FROM
APPROXIMATELY FORTY DIFFERENT
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS.
IT'S A WAY TO GET TO KNOW OUR
GOVERNMENT -- OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
ACTED ON A NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING.
AN AUGMENTATION.
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
OF UP TO SEVENTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CENSUS
OUTREACH EFFORTS.
YOU ALL KNOW THAT'S A VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR THE STATE AND
FOR THE COUNTRY THIS YEAR.
OF APPROVED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
UPGRADE AND PROTECT OUR
ELECTIONS SECURITY SYSTEMS.
WE APPROVED TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THIS INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HOUSING
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE. SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
AID FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN INNOVATIVE FINANCING
TOOLS.
SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO APPROVED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE INTENT IS FOR POLICY OF
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH THE ON
GOING HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM FOR THOSE FUNDS.
AND WE APPROVED AN ADDITIONAL
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO REDUCE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CONTRIBUTION
RATES BY ONE POINT 8%.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
FINAL SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF COURSE I ALSO WANT TO
EXTEND MY THANKS TO MY
INCREDIBLE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MEMBERS SENATOR BALANCE SENATOR
MORE LACKEY.
AND AS I KNOW ALL THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES DID WE HAD.
EXTENSIVE HEARINGS WITH.
GREAT INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA --
CDC OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND OTHERS.
ALL OF WHICH NEVER WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED AND WAS MORE THAN ABLE
LEAST STAFFED BY OUR GOOD BUDGET
STAFFERS CHRIS FRANCIS AND YOUNG
SALAS SO I THANK THEM VERY MUCH
ALSO -- AND I KNOW MY
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS DO
ADDITIONALLY.
THESE ARE THE ACTIONS WE WE TOOK.
UNDER THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WE HAVE -- WE APPROVED
FIFTEEN MILLION. TO PROVIDE.
GRANTS TO NONPROFITS FOR
SECURITY TO ASSIST IN IMPROVING
THE SECURITY.
AT OUR FACILITIES IN THE STATE
THAT MAY BE TARGETS OF HATE BUT
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED.
TO TEMPLES MOSQUES SCHOOLS AND
OTHERS.
BE PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING FUNDS TO PRE POSITION
FIRE ENGINES FOR RAPID RESPONSE
IN -- GIVEN OUR NOW ALMOST YEAR
ROUND FIRE SEASON.
WE ALSO APPROVED THIRTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION NOW FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STATE ENTITIES
TO PREPARE FOR THE SHUTDOWN
INCIDENTS THAT MAY OCCUR THAT
ARE I USE MAY NEED.
TO SHUT DOWN THE POWER.
I'M IN A REMAINING THIRTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE RECEIVED A REPORT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE OTHER WAYS TO MOST
APPROPRIATELY USE THOSE FUNDS SO
IT'S A TOTAL OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION.
WITHIN OUR ACTIONS AROUND OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE HAVE
A ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
PERSON TO COMMUNITY PIPELINE
PACKAGE. TO SUPPORT -- BETTER
PROGRAMS WITH IN OUR FACILITIES
KNOWING THAT OBVIOUSLY A GOOD
NUMBER OF OUR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ARE RELEASED TO THE
COMMUNITY AND WE WANT THE
OPTIMAL OUTCOMES FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY.
SO WE'VE PROVIDED A FUNDING FOR
REENTRY HOUSING SUPPORT AND RE
ENTRY SERVICES. FOR COMMUNITY
BASED -- REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WITHIN OUR PRISON SYSTEM. FOR
PAROLE THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT.
AND FOR FUNDING FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
ENTITIES WHO ALSO PROVIDE
REENTRY SUPPORT SERVICES TO
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THAT ATTEND THEIR INSTITUTIONS.
AND ADDITIONAL -- FOR SOME OTHER --
PURPOSES THAT WILL ASSIST US IN
ACHIEVING THOSE.
BETTER OUTCOMES FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY POINT OF VIEW.
IN TERMS OF OUR ACCESS TO
JUSTICEPACKAGE FOR OUR COURTS
WE'VE PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION ON GOING GENERAL
FUND.
WHICH IS A RESTORATION OF THE
STATE APPROPRIATION LIMIT
ADJUSTMENT.
ON OUR COURTS THIRTY NINE NINETY
MILLION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY PROVIDED
FIFTY MILLION FOR OUR FAMILY LAW
IN CIVIL COURT REPORTERS.
CAN MILLION FOR COURT
INVESTIGATORS AND COURTROOM
CLERKS. FIVE MILLION FOR COURT
REPORTER TRANSCRIPT IN IT'S AN
INCREASE.
AND TEN MILLION FOR OUR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS AND ADULT
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND FIVE
MILLION -- FOUR BUT THE EQUAL
ACCESS FUND WHICH WAS A PROGRAM
OF OUR STATE BAR BUT WILL NOW BE
INDEPENDENT.
AND WITHIN OUR CDC OUR OUR
PRISON SYSTEM WE ARE FINDING.
AN INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM AT ALL ADULT
FACILITIES THAT WILL BE -- A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO I'M
IT INCLUDES.
A MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT A COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
THERAPY PROGRAMS.
WE ALSO APPROVED THE MOVING OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE FROM OUR CDC ARE TO A
NEW DEPARTMENT UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
THE NEW NAME WILL BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
WITHIN THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS WE
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR THE
CALVET PROGRAM THAT'S OUR
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION AND THOSE GO OUT AS
GRANTS. TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN.
VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
AND THAT THOSE WERE SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF WHAT SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE OUR ACTIONS WE TOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR HOURS OF COMMITTEE WORK
AND I THINK IT HAS ULTIMATELY
RESULTED IN A BOLD LIST OF
INVESTMENTS.
ALL WITH A BALANCE OF
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING AND LONG
TERM SAVINGS.
SO WITH THAT WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE INTO BECAUSE WE WERE NOT
GONNA TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS BECAUSE OF THESE
ITEMS ARE HEARD SUBCOMMITTEE AND
PUBLIC COMMENT WAS AFFORDED.
AN OPPORTUNITY THEN --
COLLEAGUES WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO --
WILL BE TO TAKE VOTES ISSUE BY
ISSUE INDIVIDUALLY SO WE'LL HAVE
A THIRTY EIGHT ACTIONS ON THE
VOTE ONLY SINCE WE MOVED.
TO DOWN TO DISCUSSION -- OF
THOSE OF THE TABLE JUST BE
PATIENT WITH A MOMENT AS WE ROLL
THROUGH THE ACTIONS.
WITH THAT I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION UNDER ITEM ONE ZERO ONE
SIX ZERO THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
BUREAU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
APPROVE THIS BUDGET IS.
SPIN MOVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MITCHELL HI AND NIELSEN.
THAT ARE BOUND.
CENTER DID RAZA.
FENDER HER DAUGHTER.
CENTER JONES.
CENTER LEYVA.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK.
CENTER MORAL.
SENATOR PAN ALL RIGHT CENTER
ROTH.
CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER STERN.
CENTER STONE SENATOR UMBERG.
DEREK OWSKI. FOR THE VOTE OF
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM ZERO
FIVE ZERO NINE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
ISSUE TO FILM AND TELEVISION TAX
CREDIT CARRY FORWARD ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN NO AND ABOUT.
THERE DORADO.
CENTER HER DAUGHTER.
CENTER JONES.
CENTER LEYVA HI CENTER MCGUIRE.
FOR MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK [inaudible]
GENERAL.
CENTER PAN HI SARAH [inaudible]
THERE'S SKINNER.
CENTER STERN CENTER STONE
[inaudible]
CENTER AMBERG [inaudible]
CENTER MAKOWSKI.
BUT THE VOTER FIFTY THREE THAT
MOTION CARRIES MOVING ON TO ITEM
ZERO EIGHT FOUR ZERO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
ISSUE.
THREE TRIPOD.
I'VE I DIDN'T VOTE SO SHOULD BE.
FIFTEEN TO ONE IT WARMER TIME
IT'LL BE.
FIFTEEN I LAID OFF.
FIFTEEN TO FIFTEEN TO AND ONE
ABSTENTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE RECORD WILL NOW.
THE CORRECTION.
AGAIN ITEM ZERO EIGHT FOUR ZERO
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA'S THE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT ISSUE THREE I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL SENATE
MITCHELL BY ENTER NIELSEN.
AND ABOUT.
THEIR DORADO.
CENTER HER TITLE.
CENTER JONES.
CENTER LEYVA.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING FINNEMORE LOCK
[inaudible]
GENERAL.
CENTER PAN.
SENATOR ROTH SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR STERN.
CENTER STONE SENATOR UMBERG.
FEDERAL A HUSKY. EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ISSUE FOR UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES THE MOTOR
VEHICLE CANNOT ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ADOPT THE SENATE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT PACKAGE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
MITCHELL DIED NIELSEN NO.
THEIR BELL.
CENTRE DRUGO.
CENTER TADA.
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA BY STANDARD MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
IN A MORE WHAT.
CENTER MORAL.
CENTER PAN [inaudible]
SENATOR ROBB.
CENTER SKINNER.
FETTERS STERN.
CENTER STONE [inaudible]
CENTER AMBERG [inaudible]
CENTER MAKOWSKI.
WITH A CAN OF VOTE COUNT OF
FOURTEEN FOR THE MEASURE KERRY'S
[inaudible] FIVE FIVE ALL OF
THEM.
THE YOUNGER SAYS IT'S THIRTEEN
BY.
WE'RE GOING TO SLOW DOWN AND LET
HER COUNTER VOTE SHEET I
APPRECIATE YOU GENTLEMAN
MONITORING SO CLOSELY. FIVE
THIRTEEN FIVE THE MOTION STILL
KERRY'S PRECIADO.
WENT ON TO ISSUE -- UNDER THE
PART UNDER CAL FIRE.
ISSUES FIVE AND SIX ISSUE FIVE
ENHANCE FIRE PROTECTION MAY
REVISION UPDATE OF THE FEDERAL
AIR TANKERS I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. TO APPROVE THIS PROPOSED
IT'S BEEN MOVED THANK YOU --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
MITCHELL HIAND NIELSEN.
AND ABOUT. THIRTY RAZA.
INTERTOTO.
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK.
CENTER MORAL.
SENATOR PAN.
SERRA.
CENTER SKINNER [inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
CENTERS STERN.
BUT FAIR UMBERG.
CENTER WHAT COUNTY [inaudible]
THIS IS.
WITH A VOTE OF EIGHTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE SIX
INNOVATION PROCUREMENT.
BRENT.
AW I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
APPROVE REQUESTED RESOURCES WITH
MODIFICATIONS AS REFERENCE ON
PAGE TEN OF THE AGENDA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
MITCHELL FIVE NIELSEN I AND BELL.
CENTRE DRAW THOUGH.
UNDER HER TITLE CENTER JONES.
CENTER LEYVA HI IN A REQUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK.
CAMERA.
CENTER PAN.
SERRA [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER STERN.
CENTER STONE.
CENTER AMBERG.
CENTER RIGHT HEALTHY.
WITH A VOTE OF EIGHTEEN TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
ISSUE SEVEN THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN AUGMENTATION BUT WE
WILL ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE HAS BEEN MOVED
CALL THE ROLL.
ENTER MITCHELL DIED AND NIELSEN.
THEY'RE ABOUT.
CENTER DRAW THOUGH.
CENTER HER TITLE.
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
IN A MONNING.
THEY'RE MORE LOCK.
GENERAL SENATOR PAN.
SENATOR ROTH.
CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER STERN.
THERE STONE.
SENATOR UMBERG.
CENTER WAY CASKEY. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN ALL THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THE MOTIONS APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED IS BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER MITCHELL BY
SENATOR NELSON I HAVE AN ABOUT.
CENTER DRUGA.
CENTER HER DAUGHTER.
JERRY JONES SAWYER LEYVA.
THE NUMBER OF WIRE.
CENTER MINING FENNIMORE LOCK.
CENTER MORAL.
CENTER PAN.
CENTER ROTH.
THEIR SKINNER -- FAIR STERN.
CENTER STONE CENTER AMBERG.
CENTER LIKE HEALTHY. EIGHTEEN
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON ISSUE NINE UNDER THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
ALIGNMENT OF INNOVATION FUNDING
TIME LINES AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THE MOTION IS ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE MITCHELL HI AND NIELSEN.
THEIR BELL.
CENTRE DRAGO CENTER HER TARA.
THERE JONES CENTER LEYVA.
THERE MCGUIRE CENTER MONNING
CENTER MORLOCK CENTER MORAL.
CENTER PAN CENTER A FAIR SKINNER.
CENTER STERN FIRESTONE.
SENATOR UMBERG -- MICHALSKI.
EIGHTEEN ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
TAKING ALL THE ITEMS -- DID THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ISSUE TEN ELEVEN TWELVE
IN ONE MOTION.
AND LIKE FIFTY SECOND YEAH NOT A
PROBLEM ISSUE WILL TAKE A ONE AT
A TIME ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN ISSUE NUMBER TEN CANYON
SPRINGS ADMISSIONS EXPANSION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE MOTION
IS TO DROP TBL ADOPT TBL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND MITCHELL AYE
CENTER NIELSEN.
AND BELL.
THIRD RAZA.
CENTER TARA [inaudible]
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTER MORAL [inaudible]
CENTER PAN [inaudible]
CENTER ROTH [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
SENATOR STERN.
CENTER STONE [inaudible]
CENTER AMBERG.
CENTER AYE KOWSKI
.
WITH SIXTEEN ICE THE MOTION
CARRIES.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE ELEVEN PORTER
VEAL STABILIZATION TRAINING
ASSISTANCE THE REINTEGRATION
FACILITIES THE MOTIONS APPROVED
THAT'S PROPOSALS WE'VE HAD A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN I THEIR BELL
[inaudible]
SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR TARA THIRD JONES
[inaudible]
CENTER LEYVA [inaudible]
CENTER MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
FEDERAL.
CENTER PAN.
SENATOR ROTH.
CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER STERN.
CENTER STONE.
CENTER UMBERG.
CENTER LIKE OWSKI HI. EIGHTEEN
ZERO THE MEASURE KERRY'S MOVING
ON TO ISSUE WELVE HEADQUARTERS
RESTRUCTURING AND SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IN THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
LANGUAGE WE'VE GOT A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ENTER MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN AYE
CENTER BELL.
THEY'RE DORADO.
CENTER HER TITLE.
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA HI SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING [inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTER MORALE.
CENTER PAN ALL RIGHT.
CENTER ROTH.
CENTER SKINNER.
THERE IS STERN.
THERE IS DOWN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
ALL RIGHT CENTER BY CASKEY.
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO THE MIDDLE HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION ISSUE
THIRTEEN TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE MOST
IS APPROVE THIS PROPOSED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ENTER MITCHELL AYE AND NIELSEN.
REBEL FENNER DRIVES A FENDER
TADA [inaudible]
CENTER JOHN.
THERE ARE LEYVA.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MINING.
CENTER MORLOCK.
FEDERAL [inaudible]
CENTER PAN.
SENATOR ROTH.
CENTERS SKINNER.
ENTER STERN FERRIS DOWN
[inaudible]
CENTER AMBERG.
CENTER BY CASKEY.
HI. EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT MEASURE
KYRIE'S MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT ISSUE.
FOURTEEN E. I. T. C. OUT REACH
THE MOTION KEY IS.
OUR TO CONFORM WITH THE ACTIONS
OF SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR PROVIDE
LOCAL SYSTEMS REIMBURSEMENTS A
FIVE MILLION.
THE MOST HAS BEEN MAY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER MITCHELL BY
YELTSIN HI THERE VAL
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I THEY'RE DORADO.
CENTER TARA [inaudible]
THERE JONES.
CENTER LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING CENTER MORLOCK.
FEDERAL.
SENATOR PAN RIGHT SENATOR A
SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR STERN.
CENTERS DOWN.
CENTER I'M BURKE.
CENTER MY CASKEY. EIGHTEEN ZERO
THE MEASURE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION ISSUE FIFTEEN
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY PROGRAM
SUNSET REMOVAL THE MOST IS
APPROVED ASK PROPOSALS.
SO MOVE SENATOR MINING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND MATCH
UP BY THE ASCENT.
SENATOR BELL.
CENTRE DRUGA.
UNDER HER DAUGHTER.
THIRD JONES -- LEYVA.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MONNING.
CENTER MORLOCK [inaudible]
FEDERAL.
SENATOR PAN HI SENATOR A CENTERS
SKINNER.
CENTER STERN.
FARES DOWN [inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG.
I CENTER I COUNTY.
LOS ANGELES WHICH WAS THE NO
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THAT
AT A TIME ABSTRACT BUT THAT.
I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU -- FOR WITH A VOTE OF
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. SIXTEEN THROUGH --
NINETEEN AND YOUR CAUCUSES
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
OKAY IN ASKING MY JUST CUT IT UP
YEAH WELL YOU.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADD TO THAT WE
WANT TO REDO ANYTHING -- IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO UNDER
ITEM DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
ISSUE THE ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
THAT WE TAKE ONE MOTION COVERING
ISSUES SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN ALL RIGHT
DOGGETT VIEWTIFUL.
AND FURTHERMORE WE THINK THAT
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY SHOULD
ONLY HAVE TO SAY OR NOT OUR LAST
NAMES AND NOT HAVE TO FACE AN
INTERVIEW TIME.
WE GO SHAVE SECONDS OFF OF THIS
HEARING.
SO FEEL FREE JUST TO CALL
MEMBERS LIKE WE DO ON THE SENATE
FLOOR JUST BY OUR LAST NAMES.
MITCHELL.
AGAIN THE MOTION IS ITEMS THE
ISSUE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN IT'S BEEN MOVED
MITCHELL ON NEWMAN.
BELL RIGHT DRUGA HI HER DAUGHTER.
JONES.
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN.
PAN HI ROSS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN AYE STONE.
AMBERG RIGHT BY CASKEY. EIGHTEEN
ZERO THOSE MEASURES KERRY.
IT ABSOLUTELY -- ANY OTHER GROUP
BEANS -- ANYONE'S COMFORTABLE
WITH -- SHALL WE DO INDIVIDUALLY.
THIRTY FIVE I HEARD INDIVIDUALLY.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
ON ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENTS.
OF THE MOTION IS APPROVED PLACE
HOLDEN LANGUAGE WE'VE HAD A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FIVE NO [inaudible]
WELL.
DRAW THE LINE HER TARA
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MY LOOK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN RIGHT [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
MY HUSKY
.
BUT WITH A VOTE OF THIRTEEN TO
FOUR THE MOTION CARRIES MOVING
ON ISSUE TWENTY ONE SUPPLEMENT
REPORTING LANGUAGE ON EXPANSION
OF CAL FOR US TO SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS.
THE MOTION IS APPROVED
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGES BEEN MOVES
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN STATE [inaudible]
I'LL [inaudible]
DRAGO -- TARA I JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
BUT ABSTAINED RESTING ABSTAINED
WITH THAT HELP YOU [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
MORRELL.
PAN HI ROTH BUT SKINNER RIGHT
[inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE KEY.
THE OFFICIAL RECORD WILL REFLECT
TRIPS INTO THE I'M JUST NOT
ANNOUNCING INSTANCE IN THE
DESERT MOUNTAIN.
WITH A VOTE OF FIFTEEN I THE
MEASURE KERRY'S MOVING ON ISSUE
TWENTY TWO SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE ON SB TEN
FORTY ONE THE RAND REPORT.
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGES COULD MOVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN THANK [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
DRUGA [inaudible]
TARA [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. ONE MORNING.
THANK [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN RIGHT [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
I MY COUNTY. FIFTEEN THE THREE
THE MEASURE CARE IS MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN ZERO PARDON ME.
WITH A VOTE OF FIFTEEN ZERO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S ISSUE TWENTY
THREE SINGLE ALLOCATION BUDGET
METHODOLOGY CHANGES OF THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE PROPOSALS
FUNDING AND ADOPT.
PLYFULLY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD DELAY MOVEMENT OF
FUNDING FOR STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
SERVICESFROM CAL WORK SINGLE
ALLOCATION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN I'VE FOUND.
DORADO HER TARA JONES
[inaudible]
LEYVA HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
PAN RIGHT.
ROTH.
SKINNER.
RIGHT STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER RIGHT BY KATHY.
EIGHTEENTH ZERO THE MEASURE
KERRY'S.
ISSUE -- TWENTY FOUR THE CAL
WORKS OUTCOME THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW A KID
MINISTRY TO FUNDING APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL I
NIELSEN I FELL.
STRUGGLE.
HER TARA [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
EVA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING -- LOCK.
BROWN.
PAN HI ROTH [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
I CASKEY. EIGHTEEN ZERO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S ISSUE TWENTY
FIVE CAL WORKS.
BOB OUTCOMES OF ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW TBL.
THE MOTION IS PLACE HOLDER TBL
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN THEY TORONTO --
TARA.
JONES.
LEYVA AYE.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MY LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
PAN RIGHT [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
DOWN [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
I HI KATHY
.
WITH A OF VOTER.
THIRTEEN TO THREE THE MEASURE
KERRY'S MANAGE YOUR OWN MOVIE.
TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY EIGHT IS
THERE ANY CONCERN WITH TAKING
ONE MOTION FOR ISSUES TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT ONE
MOTION.
XENON I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADOPT T. B. A. L. FOR IF YU
FORTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN AND ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT TO APPROVE FUNDING
THIS PROPOSALS IS BEEN MOVED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
WELL.
DRAGO.
HER TARA.
JONES.
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
ROUND.
PAN RIGHT BY [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
I CASKEY. EIGHTEEN ZERO THOSE
THREE MEASURES PASS ISSUE TWENTY
NINE RAPID RESPONSE RESERVE. TO
DROP A DOC TBL IS THE MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
DORADO.
HER TITLE.
JONES THOUGH LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MARA [inaudible]
PAN HI [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY KATHY HI.
WITH A VOTE OF THIRTEEN TWO FIVE
THE MOTION CARRIES MOVING ON
ISSUE THIRTY CAL WORKS ASSET
TEST LIMIT.
APPROVED FUNDING AS PROPOSALS WE
HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN NO.
WELL.
RAZA.
HER TARA.
JOHNS [inaudible]
LEYVA HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN RIGHT [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY KATHY HI.
WITH A VOTE OF FOURTEEN TO FOR
THE MEASURE KERRY'S.
BUT ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
REMEMBER WE'VE MOVED ISSUE
THIRTY TWO TO THE DISCUSSION
SECTION TODAY'S AGENDA.
IS THERE ANY RESERVATION AND
TAKING ISSUES THIRTY ONE AND
THIRTY THREE IN ONE VOTE.
RECAP IS CERTAINLY -- ISSUE
pPOPULATION JUST MISSING FOR
POLLS RULES THE MOTION IS.
APPROVALS BUDGETED AND ADOPT
ELLIE -- RECOMMENDATIONS FOR T.
B. L. THAT DIRECT CDC ON A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE IT'S
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN I FELL [inaudible]
RATHER.
A TOTAL.
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I INQUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MARLA [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
FAN [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
MIKE OWSKI. FOR THE VOTE OF
EIGHTEEN ZERO THE MEASURE CARE
IS MOVING ON TO ISSUE.
THIRTY THREE RE ENTRY
PREPARATION SERVICES FOR
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING IT INTERSECTS PEOPLE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF STATE
PRISON.
THE MOTION IS APPROVALS FOR
POLLS AND FOLD INTO SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE PRISON TO COMMUNITY
PIPELINE PACKAGE WE HAVE A
MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN.
I IT'S A LIE.
THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT DRAW THOUGH.
HER TARA.
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
PAN HI [inaudible]
RON [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
RIGHT STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
OKAY NIELSEN.
I DO NOT [inaudible]
NIELSEN ITEM [inaudible]
BY KATHY.
WITH A VOTE OF THIRTEEN THE FIVE
THE MEASURE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON COLLEGE MOVING ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ISSUE THIRTY FOUR FOUR DAY
SCHOOL WEEK THE MOTION IS
APPROVED PLACEHOLDER TBL. TO
CORRECT AN EDUCATION CODE AND TO
WAIT TILL THESE TO SPECIFY
DISTRICTS OPERATING SCHOOLS ON A
FOUR DAY SCHOOL WEEK.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MITCHELL HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
DRAWS A HER TARA.
JONES.
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE.
MONNING.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
HI.
PAN.
ROTH.
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
HI KATHY. EIGHTY TWO WITH A VOTE
OF IGHTY NOW THE MEASURE
KERRY'S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE UPDATED PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
THE MOTION IS APPROVED PROP
NINETY PACKAGE IN COLLEGE YOU
HAVE AN ATTACHMENT -- THE BLUE
SHEET THAT'S BEEN DISTRIBUTED
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN STATE [inaudible]
WELL.
RAZA.
HER TARA.
JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MORNING THANK MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
NINE ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
I CASKEY [inaudible]
HI. THIRTEEN ZERO THE MEASURE
KERRY'S ISSUE THIRTY SIX UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
DIGITAL PRESERVATION ACTIVITIES
AND STATEWIDE CULTURAL INVENTORY
DEVELOPMENT.
THE MOTION TO APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED IN A DOT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MITCHELL HI NO SENT NO
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
DRUGS.
HER DAUGHTER.
JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LONG [inaudible]
MARA.
PAN HI RON [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER OF HI KATHY.
THE VOTER THIRTEEN FIVE THE
MEASURE KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IT'S
THE NEW CAMPUS STUDY THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL APPROPRIATE ONE
MILLION ONE TIME FOR REVIEW OF
POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN SAN DIEGO AN
APPROPRIATE ONE MILLION. FOR
REVIEW OF THE CAMPUS AND SILICON
VALLEY WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL AYE.
NIELSEN.
WELL [inaudible]
DRAW THE TARA [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA AYE.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING THANK [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MARA [inaudible]
PAN I ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY.
THE VOTER THIRTEEN FOR THE
MEASURE KERRY'S CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISSUE THIRTY
EIGHT RE ENTRY GRANT THE MOTION
IS.
ALL RIGHT -- WE WILL TAKE UP
ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT AND THIRTY
NINE IN ONE MOTION -- REENTRY
GRANT BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PILOT
PROGRAM.
IT WILL RETURN A KICKOFF.
OKAY -- WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
THEM ONE AT A TIME [inaudible]
ISSUE. THIRTY EIGHT RE ENTRY
GRANT.
THE THE MOTION WILL BE TO MAKE
NO CHANGES TO THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROP MANY GENERAL
FUND APPROVED BY SUBCOMMITTEE.
ONE WHICH REMAIN IN THE SENATE'S
BUDGET REDUCE THE PRESENT A
COMMUNITY PIPELINE PACKAGE
ADOPTED BY SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE BY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S THE
MOTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MITCHELL HI NIELSEN I
EL.
DORADO.
HER TARA.
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING STERN.
RIGHT STONE.
NUMBER.
RIGHT I CASKEY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PROBLEM. EIGHTEEN ZERO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY NINE THE
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PILOT
PROGRAM THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
MODIFY.
ON THE DEADLINE FOR THE LA ELSE
FINALLY VALUATION FROM JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY IT'S BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL.
BY YELTSIN I L..
DRAGO.
OUR TARA.
JOHNS [inaudible]
LEYVA.
YOUR TURN BY TURN [inaudible]
JONES I DONE THAT [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MARK.
MARA.
PAN.
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN RIGHT DOWN.
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
I COUNTY.
THE VOTE OF EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO
THE MEASURE KERRY'S.
AT THIS POINT WE WILL MOVE INTO.
THE SPACE SPACE AND THE ISSUE
NUMERICAL AMERICA -- WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH THE ITEMS THAT.
WERE PULLED FROM VOTE ONLY THREE
GOING TO BE AGAIN WITH ISSUE.
THIRTY TWO I'D LIKE TO WELCOME --
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE VAGUE THIS ONE OFTEN.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE HERE FOR
A HIS FIRST -- CLOTHING BUDGET
EXPERIENCE OUR NEW LA JOH MR
GAVE CREDIT THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US [inaudible]
PERFECT.
SO THE FIRST ITEM WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT IS ISSUE THIRTY TWO
JANITORIAL SERVICES THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FACILITY.
MR THIS ONE OFTEN.
YES ALSO WERE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
CLASSES.
EXCELLENT TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
FOR MEMBERS AND THEY WILL OPEN
UP THE IF THE LA -- HAS COME AS
WELL CENTER NIELSEN WE HAD AN
ISSUE WITH THIS LAST YEAR.
AND THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A LONG
STANDING BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
CONTRACT WITH PRIDE INDUSTRIES
[inaudible]
ANOTHER ENTITY.
ENTER THE PICTURE.
AND THEY COMPROMISE WAS ROSS AT
FIFTY FIFTY AND NOW I AM
INFORMED THAT.
ALTHOUGH THIS FIFTY FIFTY IS
SUGGESTED TO CONTINUE
[inaudible]
THAT.
GDC ARE CANNOT.
FIND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE. TO DO
THIS JOB.
WHY WOULD WE THEN CONTINUE THE?
FIFTY FIFTY SO I'LL I'LL SPEAK
VERY BRIEFLY AND FOR TURNING
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AND SAY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED. TO THE FIFTY FIFTY
MODEL AND WE BELIEVE OUR
PROPOSAL DOES PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW PRIDE TO
PERFORM ANY DUTIES TO THE EXTENT
THAT THOSE CIVIL SERVICE
POSITIONS REMAIN ON FAILED --
BUT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO INCLUDE YOU MEAN
YOU PROCEED YOU WOULD GET THE
JOB DONE LEAVING POSITIONS
VACANT.
WHAT WAS LEAVING BAKER?
IF THE VISIT OF GOD PLEASE.
CRYSTALS ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE INTENTION IS TO
CONTINUE FILLING THOSE CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS AND US YOU SEE
OUR CONTINUES -- TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS -- BUT AS YOU ALLUDED.
TO ALTERNATELY -- THERE ARE
VACANCIES CURRENTLY AND THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY IS SO THAT THE PRIDE
CONTRACT -- COULD FULFILL THOSE
WORKLOAD ACTIVITIES WALL THOSE
POSITIONS ARE BEING FILLED.
I DON'T LIKE TO SEE SOME
LANGUAGE THAN IN THE BUDGET IF
SAYING THAT IN EFFECT.
PRIDE INDUSTRIES WILL FILL THOSE
POSITIONS THEN THOSE ADDITIONAL
ABOVE 50% POSITIONS UNTIL SUCH
TIME.
I THINK -- OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CONTRACT IS IT ALREADY
PROVIDES THAT FLEXIBILITY AND
ULTIMATELY AS YOU SEE OUR FILL
THOSE POSITIONS AND WE TRY TO
REACH THAT FIFTY FIFTY SPLIT
WHICH IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
POSITIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE FOR
PRIDE -- THAT WE WOULD MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THAT SPLIT I
DON'T DISPUTE THAT WOULD GET ME
THE LANGUAGE THAT SAYS SUCH.
IN A CONTRACT.
SO I DON'T HAVE THAT LANGUAGE I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T ME RIGHT NOW.
TO FOLLOW UP.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HOLD IT IN
HERE RIGHT NOW OKAY IT'S JUST AN
ISSUE THAT'S TROUBLING LET ME
PUT IT THAT WAY.
TROUBLING OUT INVOLVED LAST YEAR.
HOW IT GOT RESOLVED AND THEN WE
WERE AGAIN TODAY SO?
JUST TO GET THAT INFORMATION.
FOR MORE LAW AND I'M SURE I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHY THIS WASN'T
HEARD AND SEVEN FIVE WHAT WELL
BEFORE SENATORS GET A RESPONSE.
LET ME CLARIFY JUST PROCEDURALLY
NOT EVERY ITEM IS A CHEN DIES IN
EVERY SUBCOMMITTEE THAT IS.
NOT WHAT WE DO BUT SENATOR
KENNEDY ONE AT ONE MEETING AND
THAT'S WHEN THEY HEARD IT WHEN I
MUST'VE BEEN ROOMS RIGHT.
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND -- WE WERE WAITING
FOR CLARIFICATION ON THE EXACT
QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED AND WE
WERE THEN -- WE WERE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE CLARIFICATION WE
WE ALSO DID NOT WANT TO HAVE --
WORK BEING DONE.
BUT THEN WHEN WE WERE AT WHEN WE
GOT THE CLARIFICATION THAT THE
CONTRACT WAS STRUCTURED SO THAT
PRIDE COULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES.
UNTIL THE CDC OUR POSITIONS WERE
FILLED -- DID.
WE'RE OKAY WITH PRECEDING BUT WE
COULDN'T TAKE OUR ACTION SOME
OTHER WORDS WITHIN CLOSE IT
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT NOW WE DO WHICH IS WHY IT'S
BEFORE THE WHOLE BODY.
METRIC JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPTICS THIS WAS AWKWARD LAST
YEAR -- SO WE HAVE SOME.
WONDERFUL PEOPLE THAT ARE
PROVIDING A SERVICE.
AND THEN WE HAVE A UNION WHO'S
SAYING WE WANT TO MAKE THOSE
UNIONIZE POSITIONS WHICH ROUTE
FINANCE STANDPOINT IS EXPENSIVE
[inaudible]
BUT BUT IT DISPLACES YOU KNOW
GROUP THAT WERE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT SO I I THINK THE OPTICS.
DEPARTMENT FINANCES JUST
CONSIDER THE OPTICS IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO EXPLAIN TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHY.
THIS WOULD BE DONE.
OUR JUST GIVE ONE EXAMPLE IN IT
IT'S IT'S IT'S SORT OF SIMILAR
BUT NOT THE SAME BUT THE ASKED
ME FILED A GRIEVANCE WITH THE
WESTERN.
MICHIGAN UNIVERSITY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE HIRED A DIFFERENT GROUP TO
TAKE CARE OF THE POISON IVY.
ON THE CAMPUS WELL THE FATHER
THE AGREEMENT BECAUSE THEY HIRED
HER TO GOATS.
HIS ARMS KANSEN LET'S JUST LET'S
NOT [inaudible]
LOOK AWKWARD.
WHEN WE WHEN WE DO CERTAIN
THINGS SPECIAL PEOPLE LIKE?
LIKE PRIDE THIS IS JUST.
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
IT'S ODD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
TO GET TO THIS SECTION NIELSEN
IS THE DURATION THE CONTRACTS TO
YOUR CONTRACT.
I BELIEVE THE TERMS THE
CONTRACTOR STILL UNDER
NEGOTIATION.
OKAY [inaudible]
AND HOW.
A CAN WE BE ASSURED THAT THESE
POSITIONS ARE IN FACT FILLED BY
PRIDE.
IT'S A DURING THE TIME THAT
NOBODY ELSE CAN PRODUCE OF THIS
YEAH YOU CANNOT PRODUCE THE
INDIVIDUALS.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT HAPPENS HOW
DO YOU REPORT TO US IT IS THIS
IS GETTING DONE YOU SAY THE JOB
GET DONE OKAY?
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT WE KNOW?
THAT THAT JOB IS DONE.
I PORTION LITTLE HARD BECAUSE I
DON'T LIKE THE WAY THIS CAME
DOWN EITHER I WAS MUCH MORE
VOCAL LAST YEAR.
JUST POWER PLAY BY UNION OKAY
SIMPLE.
AND DISABLED PEOPLE ARE
DISPLACED BECAUSE OF SO LET'S
GET SOME ANSWERS.
THE ADMINISTRATION FULLY INTENDS
ON IMPLEMENTING THE DIRECTION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
LAST YEAR TO GET TO THAT FIFTY
FIFTY SPLIT.
AND ULTIMATELY WITH CDC ARE
CARRYING SOME VACANCY IS THAT
WORK STILL NEEDS TO GET DONE IN
ORDER. FOR US TO BEING -- FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND WITH LICENSING
AGREEMENTS AND SO.
BRIGHT HAS YEAH BUT KERRY THAT
WORK FOR THE LAST SEVERAL -- A
COUPLE YEARS AND AND THEREFORE
AS WE INTEND TO CONTINUE THAT
RELATIONSHIP AND AGAIN MOVING
FORWARD -- IMPLEMENTING THE
DIRECTION THIS WILL PROVIDE IT
SHE SHE ALWAYS CARRIES HUNDREDS.
A POSITIONS TO OUR SAVINGS ARE
THESE POSITIONS TRADE AND
CAPABLE OF PERFORMING THE
FUNCTION HERE.
ARE THEY JUST GENERAL.
ON FILL POSITIONS DR.
THAT YOU HAVE STAFF.
FOR THE CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS
ARE ARE TRAINED TO CARRY OUT THE
DUTIES BUT THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRIDE HAS BEEN A A GOOD ONE AND
THAT THEY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL --
EXPERTISE -- FOR SOME OF THE
SERVICES.
SENATOR BAIL FOLLOWED BY THIRTY
SKINNER -- ENGINE -- MEMBERS I
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
LAST YEAR I FIND THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL CONSISTENT.
WITH WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR.
AND I SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET TO A RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE HAVE BEFORE US -- SO I THINK
IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
GREEN IT WAS LAST YEAR.
I SUPPORT IT I WANTED TO SAY
THAT -- BECAUSE WE HAVE A NEW
ADMINISTRATION -- THE THE WHOLE
POLICY THAT THE STATE HAS ON NON
OUR SPECIAL -- WORK FORCE PEOPLE
WITH DIFFERENT ABILITIES NEED TO
BE INCLUDED IN OUR WORK FORCE
FOR THE STATE THE STATE NEEDS TO
DEVELOP A SOCIAL NEEDS.
OF DIVERSE -- ABILITIES
WORKFORCE POLICY.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE CLARITY ON
HOW THEY CAN BE INVOLVED IN THE
WORK FORCE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN VARIOUS WAYS SO I
THINK THAT SO.
THAT'S THIS IS CONSISTENT ARE
YOU I WOULD SUPPORT THIS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'LL TAKE THAT
AS A MOST OF SENATOR BAIL
SENATOR SKINNER.
YES I APPRECIATE -- MY
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SENATOR
BILLS CLARIFICATION ON IT NOW I
SHOULD'VE INCLUDED INTO MY
ANSWER.
PRIOR THAT.
ARE JUST REMINDER TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT IT WAS OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT. FIVE
BASICALLY ADOPTED THE ACTION
THAT ENABLE TO PRY TO HAVE 50%
OF THE POSITIONS AND ENABLE THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THIS WAS LAST
YEAR.
AND WE ARE WE HAVE BEEN FURTHER
ASSURED THAT THE ACTION THAT WE
TOOK WHICH OF COURSE THAN WAS
ADOPTED BY THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET ADOPTION OF LAST YEAR IS
BEING CONTINUED.
SO.
WITH THAT I ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
XENON LA -- ANY COMMENT.
MAYBE CALL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY CONCERNS THIS PROPOSAL
APPRECIATE THAT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE.
THIRTY TWO ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE I WILL -- TAKE
MISTER BILLS COMMENT AS A MOTION
AND AGAIN THE MOTION IS APPROVED
AS BUDGET PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI WELL I'D
RATHER.
HELLO.
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MY LOCK [inaudible]
MARA [inaudible]
PAN HI [inaudible]
ROTH HI.
SKINNER.
ALL RIGHT STERN [inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
NUMBER I'VE.
HI KATHY I NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW.
THE CASE.
THAT.
WITH A VOTE OF THIRTEEN THE FOR
THAT MEASURE KERRY'S MOVING ON
TO ISSUE.
FORTY THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION IN ADVANCE
PAYMENT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
VERY HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS PROPOSAL.
AGAIN COLLEAGUES -- THIS IS
ISSUE.
FORTY THE EITC EXPANSION.
IT WAS REQUESTED THAT IT BE
MOVED OVER FOR PUBLIC DISCUSSION
OF ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS --
FINANCE I'M SORRY ALL THE MORE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST TAKE
JUST A QUICK QUESTION IS IS IS
REMOVING INTO THIS AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
THE ANALYSIS THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FIND IS THAT.
THE RATE OF FRAUD IN
CALIFORNIA'S 19% FOR THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
BUT THAT'S BETTER THAN THE
FEDERAL LEVEL APPARENTLY IT'S UP
240%.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT THE
INITIATIVE IS BY BY THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS.
ADEQUATE STAFFING TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WERE REDUCING THE LEVEL OF FRAUD.
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE J. CHAMBERLAIN IN OUR
REVENUE UNIT -- SO.
HI BUT AND I'VE I'VE NOT HEARD
THE STATISTICS OF 90% FRIDAY --
BE HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THEM BUT
WE HAVE.
GIVEN -- FRIDGES SEX WORD WRAP A
RESOURCES. TO TO VERIFY -- THAT
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT ARE
ARE GOING PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
EARNED OF THE THE INCOME AND TO
MAKE SURE THERE ARE.
THAT THERE ISN'T -- ARE AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE THAT IT ISN'T YOUR
HAVING FRAUDULENT RETURNS WHERE
SOMEONE TAKE SOMEONE ELSE SO
SECURITY NUMBER FILE SO.
OTHERS BEEN QUITE A BIT OF OF
WORK AND AND RESOURCES PUT INTO --
PREVENT IT HAPPENING FRAUD AND
AND WHICH CALL FRONT THERE'S
THERE'S ALSO -- THERE ARE PEOPLE.
WHO DO CLAIM -- THE CREDIT.
THINKING THAT THE ARE YOU FOR
INSTANCE THAT THEY THAT A CHILD.
IS A DEPENDENT.
BUT MEDIA JOINT CUSTODY CASE THE
CHILD MAY BE MAY BE THE
DEPENDENT.
TECHNICALLY OF THE OTHER PARENT
AND SO THERE ARE MANY CASES
WHERE -- AFTER WE WILL DENY A
CREDIT BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY THEY
DETECT SOMETHING ON THEIR TURN
THIS SHOWS THAT THAT.
INDIVIDUALS NOT ENTITLED TO THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT BUT I
DON'T CONSIDER THAT FRAUD IN THE
SENSE THAT THERE THERE'S MONEY
GOING OUT -- THAT THAT ISN'T
DESERVED UNDER THE CREDIT OR OR
COULD JUST SURFACE WHEN WHEN IT
RETURNS ARE FILED ELECTRONICALLY
WHICH IS SHOW UP THAT DAY YOU
CAN'T EVEN DO WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T PRESS THE
DEPENDENT.
YOU KNOW SQUARE RIGHT SO TRY
BOUNCING OUT AUTOMATICALLY BUT I
JUST WONDER IF.
IF THAT THE LEVELS ARE THAT HIDE
IT THAT THEY'RE SAYING IT'S 40%
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND YET IT'S A LOAN.
NATIONWIDE IS IS I UNDERSTAND.
IT SO BUT BUT THAT'S THAT THAT
MEANS THERE'S COMMITTEE AT AN
ADDED EFFORT TO LOOK AT THOSE.
CREDIT SO WHICH MEANS THAT MAY
BE.
A LOT OF OUR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO A TAX AUDIT I'M JUST KIND OF
WONDERING.
IF THAT WOULD DISCOURAGE A LOT
OF PEOPLETHAT SHOULD BE TAKING
THE CREDIT FROM DOING SO IF THAT.
IS HAPPENING.
I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE -- A
FULL TAX AUDIT IT WOULD BE MORE --
AN ANALYSIS OF THE TAX RETURN TO
SEE IF.
IF THEY HAVE ALL ALL THE
CRITERIA AND THE THEY CAN YOU
KNOW.
IF THEY'VE GOT A AS A A
QUALIFIED DEPENDENT QUALIFY
INDEPENDENT OR MAYBE THEY'RE
PREPARING IT MANUALLY THEN AND
THE RATS WITH A TRIBUTE BECAUSE
IF THERE WERE ELECTRONIC IT
PROBABLY WOULD SELF CORRECT I
WOULD [inaudible]
SHE WHICH WOULD SORT ALL CASES
BUT GENERALLY I THINK.
THE FOR WHAT HAPPENED USE A PAID
TAX PREPARER TO ORDER OR
TURBOTAX OR SOMETHING.
OKAY I I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
SEE MADAM CHAIR THAT.
IT IS WE TRY TO DO GOOD THINGS
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE FIND THAT
SOME PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT THAT OFFICE AND THEN
EVERYBODY ELSE GETS CAUGHT IN
THE NET NUMBERS.
GET LETTERS IN WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE US THE FOLLOWING IN.
THAT JUST SCARES A LOT OF PEOPLE
AS WELL.
THANK YOU VENTURE.
N. S. INTERESTED IT'S GOOD TO
KNOW THAT WE ARE AT LEAST BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE -- SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CERTAINLY
SHARE MY COLLEAGUES CONCERN TO
BE SURE THAT WE ARE TRYING -- TO
CIRCUIT INTEGRITY OF OUR EITC IT
AGAIN I THINK -- MULTIPLE PEOPLE
OF NOTED THAT IT'S THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL -- MAYBE JUDGE THE
SUCCESSFUL -- YOU KNOW
INNOVATION THE TRIED AND TRIED --
TO TO HELP -- DRESS -- POVERTY
BUT I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
IRS HAS SAID PREVIOUSLY
ESTIMATED.
THAT ESSENTIALLY THE OVER
PAYMENT RATE IS ABOUT 2226% SO
THAT'S NOT NESTLE OFF FRAUD
EITHER SO I'M NOT SURE THE 40%
CAME FROM.
BUT THE IRS SAID 2226% OF OVER
PAYMENTS AND THE THEY NOTE THAT
MOST OF THE ERRORS ARE RESULTING
FROM -- YELLED COMPLEXITY THE
RULES AND AIRS AND FILING SO
AGAIN IF YOU'RE THIS IS NOT
INTENTIONAL.
NECESSARILY -- SO I I THINK BY I
WANT.
TO BE SURE THAT WERE USING
ACTION INFORMATION TRYING MAKE
POLICY THANK YOU.
PERFECT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
BELIAU ANY COMMENT.
ABOUT WILL OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
ISSUE.
pMADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
PROPOSAL FOR ALL AND WE SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION BOB
THIS IS GOING TO BE GREAT FOR
LOW INCOME WORKING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE AT THE RIGHT TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MEMBERS COUNTY MUST WITH TE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WE ALSO SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
NOT REALLY SO NOBODY WITH UNITED
WAY SO CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AND ARCH YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS --
THIS TRIP ROGERS FROM GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY -- WE ASK OUR
COLLEAGUES -- POSITION -- AND
HOPE YOU VOTE FOR THE SEPARATE
NATION THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY BRENNAN
WITH US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SUB OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE ARE ALSO A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- WOULD
LIKE TO REFERENCE -- THE
INCLUSION OF I TEN FILERS --
THESE ARE LOW INCOME -- MOSTLY
AT WHAT IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
BACKBONE OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES --
THEY'RE VERY -- LE DESERVING OF
BEING INCLUDED -- AND DECIDE IN
THIS PROPOSAL BUT WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFERING IT WOULD --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHERE INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- PURSUANT
TO PAGE FORTY FOUR ON THE AGENDA
TO APPROVE THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED EXPANSION OF THE E. I.
T. C. -- WITH -- THE ANNOTATED
CHANGES WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL.
HI.
NO.
DRAWS UP.
HER TARA.
JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
WARLOCK THEY LARA.
CAN I RUN.
GONNA DRIVE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
I CASKEY [inaudible]
HI.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE FORTY ONE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS
[inaudible]
SO.
SO FOR OUR DMV PROPOSAL WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE NUMBER OF
COMPONENTS THERE ARE CUSTOMER
SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS.
THEIR OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS
CHANGES TO OUR IT SYSTEMS AND
INCREASING TEMPORARY POSITIONS
AND SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASE IN
REAL ID DEMAND AT DMV FIELD
OFFICES.
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL.
QUESTIONS ON THE DMB PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
ELLIE.
BUT LET ME HAVE THE LA ALKALINE
ELIA.
THE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- NO COMMENTS
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE EXCELLENT
SENATOR NIELSEN.
QUESTION OF THE YOU PROVIDE PER
PER PER PROPOSING A FURTHER OVER
DRAFT IN THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT.
THE FUNDS.
AND SUSPENDING SOME CONSTRUCTION.
AS WOULD BE NECESSARY -- WHY DO
YOU FEEL THAT THERE'S A NEED TO
SUSPEND THESE [inaudible]
SAFETY IMPROVEMENT.
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S THE ACCIDENT
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT REQUIRES A?
WE BASICALLY AND I'LL TURN OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE BUT WE BASICALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO FIND INCLUDING THIS
TEMPORARY SPIKE IN REAL ID.
WHILE ENSURING THAT THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT IS SOLVE AND
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
MEN ARE DEPARTMENT FINNCE -- IN
TERMS OF THAT WE DO OUR PROPOSAL
DOES KEEP HIM OUT OF IT VEHICLE
ACCOUNTS ALL THAT AND WE DON'T
PROPOSE WE PROPOSE SHIFTING --
THESE PROPOSALS FROM CASH FUNDED
AND THE A TO PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND IN ORDER TO
KEEP A MOVE.
MOVING FORWARD SO IN FACT YOU'RE
JUST PUTTING FORTH THE RESERVE
THERE CORRECT.
OUR PROPOSAL MAINTAIN FEEL IF
YOU WILL.
WHAT WOULD YOU CAUGHT? FIFTY WE
ARE MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN BOTH
FIND THIS TEMPORARY SPIKE AND
WORKLOAD AT DMV FIELD OFFICES AS
WELL AS MOVE FORWARD WITH.
FUNDING -- SOME CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS ON A CASH BASIS AND
SOME ON A PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND BASIS TO OUT
THE PROJECTS TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND IS IS IT BASED ON THE FACT
THAT.
THE REAL ID BECAME SUCH A FIASCO.
THE NOW THAT [inaudible] TO READ.
YOU GOT TO BACKFILL SO TO SPEAK
BECAUSE OF THAT THERE OR OR
DIFFICULTY JEALOUSY.
THE THE REAL ID PROPOSAL IS THE
REAL ID Là IS A FEDERAL LAW
THAT -- WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND
THE DEADLINE. FOR IT TO FOR
SOMEONE TO HAVE A REAL ID BEFORE
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FLY IS
OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS FOR THAT PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA WEREN'T.
FINALIZING TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
EVEN THE LAW WAS PASSED PRIOR TO
THAT SO WE DO HAVE TO ADJUST TO
THAT FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
IT AND HOW DO YOU FEEL YOUR
STAND NOW AND AS FAR AS THIS
BUDGET IS TO STERN.
CONCERN PROCEEDING WITH.
THE COMPLETION THE REAL ID
THAT'S A LONG AND COMPLICATED.
AND BECOME MORE COMPLICATED
ACTUALLY.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE WERE CHALLENGES WITH REAL
ID AND THEN THERE ARE CHALLENGES
AT THE DMV MORE BROADLY THAT ARE
AGGRAVATED BY THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE THIS IMPENDING DEADLINE.
NEXT YEAR SO THE CHANGES THAT WE
ARE SUGGESTING ARE PROPOSING FOR
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT ARE
BASICALLY TO PUT A LOT OF
RESOURCES INTO THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
A LOT OF IT DRIVEN BY REAL ID
BUT NOT ALL OF THAT BECAUSE WE
KNOW EVEN WHEN RELY DE EVEN WHEN
WE GET THROUGH IF AND WHEN WE
GET TO THAT DEADLINES WE STILL
HAVE TO MAKE SURE TO REDUCE WAIT
TIMES WE STILL HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN.
PEOPLE COME TO THESE FIELD
OFFICES THEY KNOW WHAT DOCUMENTS
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO BRING IN
THEIR NOT SENT HOME AND CAN NEED
TO COME BACK AGAIN.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN SWIPE THEIR CREDIT CARD AT A
FIELD OFFICE SO ALL OF THESE TO
REQUIRE SOME UP FRONT INVESTMENT
AT THE VERY SAME TIME THAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH THE IMPENDING
REAL ID DEADLINE.
I'LL JUST BE LABOR THIS IS
SECOND IS KIND OF A IN A RATING
A COMPLAINT FROM THE FIELD.
THAT IN THE OFFICES ONE THERE IS
A BREAK TIME.
A GIVEN WINDOW.
WE'LL BE JUST VACATED.
DURING THAT BREAK THERE'S NO ONE
TO BACK FILL IT IS AT GENERAL
STAFFING POLICY IT BMB.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT SPECIFIC
pPART OF THESE CHANGES WE ARE
INVESTING A LOT IN TRAINING AND
MAKING SURE AND NOT JUST
MANAGEMENT OF SPECIFIC OFFICES
BUT REGIONAL MANAGEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A BETTER
EXPERIENCE THERE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S DESIRED.
THIRTY WILL.
FALL BY FILLMORE Là.
JUST TO LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW
THAT -- THE TRANSPORTATION --
COMMITTEE OF THE SENATE AS HARD
INTENTIONAL STAFF TO WORK JUST
SPECIFICALLY ON THE DMV.
SO WILL BE DEDICATING A LOT OF
ENERGY -- REVIEWING AND WE'RE
SUPPORTER OF THE DMV.
BUT THE DMV CLEARLY NEEDS TO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO MEET TO
THE REAL ID WORKLOAD -- WE NEED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE RESOURCES
WILL BE ADEQUATELY.
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS AND HAVE
THE STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO TRACK.
DMV PROGRESS IN MEETING THE
CHALLENGE SO STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY BE CRITICAL.
AND AFFECTED PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE D. V. D. M. V. IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO THAT END THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AND IMPROVE
IMPLEMENTING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON WAIT TIME HIRING
TECHNOLOGY -- PROPOSALS AS WELL
AS THE DMV'S RESPONSE.
THE RESPONSE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AUDIT.
AND THE STRIKE TEAMS
RECOMMENDATION WILL BE CRITICAL
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE --
CONCERT REVIEW OF THE DMV -- AND
IT IT'S CONCERNING ME THAT THE
OCTOBER -- TWENTY TWENTY DATE --
FOR REAL ID -- WILL REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
MONTHLY -- NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT THEY WILL NEED
TO BE TAKEN PLACE.
AND THE THE BASIC QUESTION IS --
THIS BUDGET PLAN IS BEING
SUBMITTED -- WILL IT -- HAVE THE
NECESSARY -- ADDITIONAL STAFF
AND EFFORT -- WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MEET THE TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE FOR REAL ID FOR
THE TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT
NEED TO RECEIVE THE GRILL ID --
BY OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY IS IS
THAT A YES OR IS THAT A NO.
I'LL JUST SAY BRIEFLY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGES AND THE
FACT THAT BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY
TWENTY IT'S A LITTLE OVER A YEAR
AND CLOSE TO YOUR NAPA WE'VE GOT
TWO SUMMERS AND SUMMERS
TYPICALLY WHEN THE DMV FACES.
THE MOST DEMAND BUT WHAT WE DO
HAVE IN OUR PROPOSAL IS NEARLY
TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
TEMPORARY POSITIONS SPECIFICALLY
TEMPORARY BECAUSE THEY'RE
DESIGNED TO MEET THIS NEED SO WE
THINK IT'LL MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
SIMPLE BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S WELL DESIGNED TO MEET.
THAT NEED WILL ARE YOU MEET THE
DEADLINE OF THE TWENTY MILLION.
APPLICATIONS BY.
OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY IS THIS PLAN IS A
PLAN YOU HAVE.
WILL ACCOMPLISH THAT THAT'S THE
KEY QUESTIONS.
THE PLAN WILL ACCOMPLISH IT OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS INCLUDING AFTER
THE TWENTY TWENTY DEBT FIE.
BECAUSE THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO IF YOU HAVE A PASSPORT YOU
DON'T NEED A REAL ID TO FLY YOU
BRING YOUR PASSPORT WITH YOU --
AND SO IT IS.
NOT REQUIRED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S EVERYONE GET A REAL ID IT
IS OPTIONAL BUT WE BELIEVE THAT --
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES --
FOR TO TO ADDRESS THOSE COMING
IN AND PART OF YOUR BILL
LANGUAGE MINING WILL.
BOTH LEGISLATIVE MINISTRATION
CONTINUE TO MONITOR.
SO THEN THE QUESTION WOULD BE IF
YOU CAN'T DO THE TWENTY TWENTY
OCTOBER -- DEADLINE FOR THE
TWENTY MILLION -- PEOPLE THAT
NEED A REAL REAL ID HOW MANY.
REAL IDEA APPLICATION SO YOU CAN
COMPLETE BY. TWENTY TWENTY WITH
THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDS YOU'RE
RECEIVING.
A IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
WINTERS A NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
AND BUDGET YEAR AT NINE POINT
THREE MILLION IN BUT YEAR PLUS
ONE THE PROXIMATE QUARTER OF
THAT WOULD BE IN THE FIRST.
QUARTER SO.
TOP THIRTEEN MILLION.
OKAY SO -- SO THE QUESTION IS IN
THE OUT YEARS -- THE REAL ID
EXTRA TEMPORARY.
ALLOCATION WILL CONTINUE.
AND WITH WE NEED IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN MONITORING THIS.
HOW MUCH CHAU?
HOW LONG THAT ADDED REVENUE WILL
BE NEEDED?
AND WHEN WILL THAT -- THAT OUT
THE REQUESTED OF THE LEGISLATURE.
BE REDUCED AT SOME POINT I
IMAGINE WHEN YOU START TO TAIL
DOWN.
THE REAL ID EXPANSION IS SPECIAL
EXPENDITURES AS I KHôNG.
OUR PROPOSAL DOES HAVE THE
HIGHEST RESOURCES IN BUDGET YEAR
AND IT IT DOES RAMP DOWN
DRAMATICALLY AFTER. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU AND I THINK
THE I APPRECIATE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE I'M A SUPPORTTHE
RECOMMENDATION MANAGER WITH THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAD
A QUICK QUESTION -- OR MAYBE A
FOLLOW P BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THE
INCREASED COSTS FOR THE DMV.
THAT THAT A PART OF THAT IS DUE
TO THE FACT THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO WAIVE THE MERCHANT FEAR THE
CREDIT CARD CONVENIENCE FEE WHEN
THEY USE THEIR CREDIT CARDS IS
THAT CORRECT.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS TO
ACTUALLY PASS ON THAT FEE
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT SEVERAL
OTHER GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS --
TO TO THE PERSON AT THE DMV --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT -- IT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE THERE'S
CONTINUING CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT [inaudible]
CHAU.
I IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO WAVE.
CONVENIENCE FEES WHEN I WAS A
COUNTY TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
SO I'M WONDERING DO YOU NEED
LANGUAGE IN YOUR TRAILER BILL TO
ALLOW THE DMV TO WAIVE.
THAT POLICE HAD SORT OF A GIFT
OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
AND SO DO.
A RE IF BARBIE ACCOUNTING FOR
THAT IN IN IN.
YOUR TRAILER BILL SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES NOT
WAIVE THOSE FEES -- IT PASSES
THEM ON TO THE PERSON APPLYING
FOR THAT RELY DEAR ENOUGH FOR
ANY SORT OF BAD TRANSACTIONS OR
CREDIT CARD. TO THEM MY FIRST
QUESTION THE ANSWER IS THEY THEY
ARE NOT BEING WAIVED CORRECT YES
OKAY SO THEN I JUST HAD THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT THAT'S THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OKAY I THINK IT COMES
WITH IT. TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE'VE THOSE SHADED.
SO I I'D SPEAKING WITH THAT
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF IDEAS AROUND THIS.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO WORK WITH
VISA AND SAY HEY WE WERE
GOVERNMENT WE'RE NOT A STORE
COMPETING WITH OTHER STORES.
WATCH GIVES A GOVERNMENT
CONVENIENCE FEE RATE WHICH IS
LIKE SHOULD BE LIKE.
POINT 1% SET UP TWO OR 3% IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO GET.
GIVE YOUR HATS A LOT OF MONEY --
BUT IF IF WE'RE WORKING ON
PRESCRIPTIONS AND PHARMACY
BECAUSE THAT'S FOR CURRENT.
VISA COSTS TO WITH THE POWER OF
ALL OF OUR MUNICIPALITIES TO
KIND OF MAKE A DENT IN THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SYNONYME OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AGAIN ON ISSUE.
FORTY ONE SCENE -- NINE ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- AS
REFLECTED IN PAGE FORTY SIX OF
THE AGENDA.
MOVE.
THANK YOU TO APPROVE. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY SIX POINT ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR REAL ID
WORKLOAD IN.
THE IN THE OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS APPROVED TEN
MILLION ON GOING INTO POSITIONS
FOR TRAINING IN NINETY REFRESH
PURPOSES [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED LET'S PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN ABSTAINED.
WELL I DRAWS A HER TARA HI
[inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
GOOD MORNING.
MORE LONG BEING [inaudible]
MARA [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN
MOVING ON TO ISSUE FORTY TWO
PREMIUM AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE
AN INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY.
THANK YOU WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE MANDATE
PENALTY OR SUBSIDY PROPOSAL.
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
ON ISSUE [inaudible]
FORTY TWO HELLO.
WE PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED ARE
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE AND DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- SEEN NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS LET'S.
IT IS NOT A GOOD FIT IN THE
OFFICE.
THE STICKER PROGRAM.
COULD THAT BE RE TASK FROM DMV
TO THEIR BOARD IS THAT A
POSSIBILITY WOULD THAT BE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT.
AT THE RIVER CAN STRETCH.
I'M ON HEALTH CARE OKAY IF YOU
FORTY TWO YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE NBA WELL IF I THOUGHT WE
WANT TO GO -- I DISCLOSED THAT
DMD SOMEONE ISSUE FORTY TWO
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS ALLEGE THE
STATE AND LOCAL OKAY ALL RIGHT --
ANY QUESTIONS THAT ISSUE.
FORTY TWO SEEING NONE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE HAVE TWO NEW MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND JDS HERE ON BEHALF
OF HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL.
AND ALSO THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY.
WE TOO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF
WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR AROUND --
A LOWERING -- THE INCLUDING
INDIVIDUALS BELOW 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE AS THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE -- PAYING THE
ARE SUBJECT TO THE PENALTY AS
WELL AS A MORE COSTS AND TH COST
SINCE THE DAY OF AND SO MORE
LIKELY TO TO TAKE UP COVERAGE IF
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU.
MR MADAM CHAIRMAN AND CHAIRWOMAN
AND ENATORS THERESA START WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE US SENATE
VERSION TODAY AROUND THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE IN THE
SUBSIDIES IN PARTICULAR I WANT.
TO THANK YOU FOR THE LANGUAGE
AROUND HEALTH CARE SHARING
MINISTRY AS IT IS A REALLY%
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND IT WILL PROVIDE -- IMPORTANT
AND ROBUST COVERAGE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TODAY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A JENNIFER ALI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS WE ALSO -- SUPPORT
THE ESTABLISHMENT THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE EXPANSION THE SUBSIDIES
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTER
WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS A
CALIFORNIA WESUPPORT THE SENATE
MOTION TODAY NURTURES PART.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS ROSANNA CURVATURE HERE
BEHALF OF THE LINES OF HEALTH
CARE SHARING MINISTRY AS WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO BE OPPOSED
TO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
ISSUE.
FORTY TWO WHICH WILL EXCLUDE
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY AS
FROM THE EXEMPTIONS TO THE
MANDATE REQUIREMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE HEALTH OF THE
ALLIANCE OF HEALTH CARE SHARING
MINISTRY IT REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE REJECT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO EXCLUDE THE
EXEMPTION TO THE MANDATE
REQUIREMENT.
AND INSTEAD URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN THE MAY REVISE
AN INDIVIDUAL MANDATE TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH.
FEDERAL LAW HEALTH CARE SHARING
MINISTRY IS OUR WAY FOR
COMMUNITIES OF ALL FAITHS --
WHERE MEMBERS HELP OTHER MEMBERS
WITH THE COSTS OF MEDICAL NEEDS
THE ALLIANCE MEMBERS HAVE OVER
THREE DECADES OF EXPERIENCE AND
FACILITATE MONTHLY SHARING OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF MEDICAL
NEEDS AMONGST THEIR MEMBERS --
HEALTHCARE SHARING IT HAS BEEN.
AROUND IN THIS COUNTRY SINCE ITS
INCEPTION THE AMISH AND
MENNONITES ARE THEY ARE THE BEST
KNOWN PRACTITIONERS OF HEALTH
CARE SHARING.
AND THE DRAFTERS OF THE ACA
RECOGNIZE THIS -- AS A VIABLE
WAY TO ADDRESS HEALTHCARE COSTS
BY EX INCLUDING THEM IN THE
EXEMPTIONS AND THE FEDERAL
MANDATE REQUIREMENTS.
THE HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY
IS JUST ONE OF NINE EXEMPTIONS
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE A. C.
A. I. SIGNED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TEN THE
EXEMPTION FOR SHARING MINISTRIES --
IS NOT A CREATION OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION JUST BY -- ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SAID IN THE PAST -- AND
THEN IN ADDITION THEIR OR THEIR
FIVE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRED TO
RECEIVE -- AN EXEMPTION AND OF
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY AS
THEY MUST BE NONPROFIT THEY MUST
SHARE A COMMON SET OF ETHICS
ETHICAL OR RELIGIOUS BELIEFS AND
SHARE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THEY ARE MUST RETAIN MEMBERSHIP
EVEN AFTER A MEDICAL CONDITION
IS DEVELOPED -- THEY AND THEY
MUST HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE AT
ALL TIMES SINCE DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE OF NINETY NINE WHICH AS YOU
KNOW WAS PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
AND THEY ALSO MUST CONDUCT AN
ANNUAL -- INDEPENDENT ON IT AND
THEN LASTLY CMS HHS AND I IN THE
IRS ALL HAD TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
THE ACA -- ONE OF THOSE WAS THAT
CMS AND HHS HAVE TO CERTIFY THAT --
HEALTHCARE SCHERING MINISTRIES
WERE EXEMPT FROM THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE HEALTH OF THE ALLIANCE OF
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY AS
HAVE THOSE CERTIFICATION LETTERS
FROM CMS IN A TREE SAYS.
ON THEIR WEBSITE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
TO ELIMINATE THE EXEMPTION OF
THE MANDATE PENALTY FOR HEALTH
CARE SHARING MINISTRY IS AND
AGAIN REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
BUT A LOT OF SPORTS [inaudible]
LAST.
ELIMINATES EXEMPTION. FOR HELP
FOR YOUR NATIONAL BUSINESS MODEL
YEAR.
CAN WE HAVE A RESPONSE FOR STAFF
TO THAT LAST -- DOCTOR PAN
CERTAINLY IT WAS HURTING YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE DOCTOR PANEL
RESPOND YES THANK YOU AND I THE
FISH INCREASE SHAPE THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE THIS ISSUE
I THINK THE THE THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN -- THAT --
DESPITE THE SECTIONS THAT
BASICALLY FOR EXAMPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE ACTUALLY HAVE
STANDARDS THAT WE SET AN ANSWER
FORCED BY THE FARM AND HEALTH
CARE BECAUSE WHEN WE SAY THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO PAY.
PREMIUMS THAT WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT THE PLANS ARE THERE WHEN --
WHEN THEY NEED THEM RIGHT SO YOU
ARE PAYING INTO A?
POOL ARE YOU PAYING IT FOR
INSURANCE YOU ON BE SURE THAT
SERVICES THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO AND AND HONORED THE
ESSENTIALLY THE CONTRACT NOW THE
CHALLENGE WITH HEALTH CARE
MINISTRIES.
CERTAINLY THEY ARE NOT INSURANCE.
BUT THEY ARE IS A CLICK
MEMBERSHIP FEES AND THEN THEY
AND DATE PAY FOR SOME THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS BUT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT THE MEDICAL.
BILLS WILL BE SHARED ARE PAID
AND SO THE CHALLENGE HERE IS IS
THAT -- THAT IN THAT -- HEALTH
CARE MINISTRIES UNFORTUNATELY
THEY DON'T HAVE TO MEET -- THE
SAME KIND OF STANDARDS OR EVEN
CLOSE IN TERMS OF ENSURING
DEFICIT FISCAL VIABILITY AND
DISABILITY AND THERE'S A BIG
CONCERN IS IS THAT WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT BY THE WAY WHENEVER YOU
HAVE AN ENTITY THAT SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE -- COVERAGE
WHEN SOMEONE PAYS INTO IT
WHATEVER IT IS -- THAT IF WHEN
THEY COLLAPSE OR THEIR NINETY
WILL MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS THAT
EXPENSE ENDS UP BEING PASSED ON
TO ALL THE REST OF US BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
THAT ENTITY WHETHER IT'S
INSURANCE COMPANY OR HAVE
CHEMISTRY THEY CAN'T PAY OUT
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO PAY OUT.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS OF COURSE THE
PERSON DOESN'T HAVE THE COVERAGE
THE FULL STILL BE SICK THEY'LL
SHOW UP IN THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY.
NO GO BANKRUPT BUT THEN THE THE
THE EXPENSE GETS SPREAD OUT
AMONGST EVERYONE ELSE SO I THINK
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE
BEHIND -- WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE SAYING THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
HAVE -- COVERAGE THAT IS THERE
AND AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND SO
AND FORTY BECAUSE HEALTH CARE%
MINISTRIES DO NOT FIT IN THE
CONTEXT.
OF ANY SORT OF FEEL THEY'RE NOT
REGULATED -- THE THEY'RE NOT
THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT UNLIKE WHAT
WE REQUIRE FOR HEALTH PLANS AND
THEY OFTEN COMPLAIN ABOUT IT TO
US HERE IN THIS VERY ROOM BUT
THEY THEY HAVE TO MEET -- VERY
YES THEY HAVE TO MEET -- FISCAL
RESERVE REQUIREMENTS OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS ASSURE THAT THEY ARE
PRESENT AND SO AT WE DO NOT FEEL
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
INCUDE ENTITIES THAT DID NOT
HAVE THOSE -- THOSE PROTECTIONS --
TO TO COUNT -- AS AS HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
PANTHER MORLOCK.
SO I'M JUST CREATIONS WE TALKED
ABOUT STATISTICS EARLIER TODAY --
TOO WE HAVE ANY.
ORGANIZATION OF THIS NATURE
THAT'S ACTUALLY.
DEFAULTED RUBIO TWENTY YEARS OF
HISTORY I'M JUST IF WE HAVE A
BUSINESS MODEL THAT HASN'T HAD A
THE PROBLEM I'M I'M WONDERING
WHY.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD SPUR.
SOMETHING DISTRICT ADDICTS.
WELL I WOULD SAY FIRST OF ALL --
IT MAINLY WE DON'T HAVE -- THAT
WHILE THERE ARE SO I THINK
THERE'S ONE COMPANY THAT MARKETS
THE CALIFORNIANS WITH --
CALIFORNIA HASN'T HAD -- THAT
MANY HEALTH CARE MINISTRIES IN
OUR STATE -- THEY ARE MORE
EXISTENCE AND OTHER PLACES BUT
THERE AGAIN I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME.
BUT I THINK IT WAS CERTAINLY
HEARD STORIES WHERE AGAIN SO
FORGET THIS IS NOT INSURANCE SO
WHAT HAPPENS THEY DON'T PROMISE
THAT -- THE MEDICAL BILLS CAN BE
PAID SO NOT TRULY COOPERATED IS
I'M SURE THEY WERE RE INSURANCE
TO COVER YEAH SO RIGHT SO HE TO
TO THE CHALLENGES OF WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT IF THEY SAY WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN'T COVER
THAT ARE WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
COVER.
THAT THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
PERSON WHO NEEDS CARE SPECIALLY
FAIRLY EXPENSIVE CARE INSURANCE
COMPANIES DO THAT TO YOU TOO
WELL ACTUALLY THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE REGULATED BY THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH CARE SO THEY
CAN ONLY DENY CERTAIN THINGS AND
IN FACT IF THEY DENY YOU -- AND
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FEEL TO
TEAMMATES SEE -- TO SAY LOOK YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY THIS IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY I NEED TO HAVE THIS
COVERAGE SO WE HAVE MECHANISMS
IN PLACE TO PROTECT PEOPLEWHEN
THEY BUY HEALTH INSURANCE.
I'M NOT SAYING TO ALWAYS PERFECT
BUT WE HAVE THOSE MECHANISMS AND
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY FILE --
WITH THAT WITH THE REGULATOR
PROOF OF THAT THEY HAVE AN
ADEQUATE NETWORK THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESERVES AND SO FORTH -- THESE
MINISTRIES DO NOT AND SO WE
DON'T WE WE DO NOT -- NO OTHER
DAY ACTUALLY HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO PROVIDE THE CARE AND THEY MAY
BE HOPING THAT SOMEONE DOESN'T
GET REALLY SICK.
SO THEN ONCE YOU HAVE A FIVE
YEAR PHASE IN TO SAVE YOUR YOU
GOT A STARTED ACTING TO A
REGULATORY MODEL AS OPPOSED TO
JUST CUT THEM OFF.
WELL CERTAINLY THEY HAVE NOT HAD
A CONVERSATION WITH US ABOUT
SAYING THAT THEY SEEK OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATION BY TEAMMATES SEE
[inaudible]
SENATOR JONES.
I'M SORRY -- SIR MARK READ READ
AND I WANT TO CUT YOU OFF YOUR
HONOR.
I'M SORRY -- THE MANAGER I AM I
AM AM HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE DIALOGUE THAT WE'RE
LISTENING TO RIGHT NOW AND THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE WITNESS.
AND THE THE INFORMATION WE'RE
RECEIVING FROM THE DíAS.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THESE
MEDICAL SHARE PROGRAMS AT BY ANY
MEANS.
I AM VAGUELY FAMILIAR WITH SOME.
I'M CONCERNED THAT -- I MEAN I I
JUST I'M.
FINDING IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY HAVE NO OVERSIGHT.
OR THAT THERE'S NO CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATION ON THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO RIDE THE
MEDICAL COVERAGE THAT THEY ARE
SAYING THAT THEY DO COVER.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE MIGHT BE
GETTING INTO SOME RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM -- CHALLENGES HERE IN
SOME FIRST AMENDMENT CHALLENGES --
ON THE U. S. CONSTITUTION SO I'M
GONNA VOTE NO ON THAT THIS IS
RIFE WITH -- POTENTIAL LEGAL
PROBLEMS.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS FULLY COOKED RIGHT
NOW.
AND I'M GOING TO VOTE NO I'M AND
ENCOURAGE THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO.
AND HAVE ENCOURAGE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AN APARTMENT
FINANCE TO COME BACK.
WITH MORE ANSWERS -- THAT I
THINK IS CENTER MORALE BROUGHT
UP.
THAT WERE NOT -- COMPLETELY
ANSWERED FROM THE DíAS -- THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
SO LET ME JUST CLARIFY THAT THE
THIS IS NOT THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
THIS ELEMENT IS NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL OKAY
THIS IS A PART OF THE SENATE
PROPOSALS IN TERMS OF WHO WERE
MAYBE WE NEED TO GET OUR DUCKS
IN A ROW.
TO SOLVE BUT LET ME JUST BE
CLEAR ABOUT -- WHEN OUR DUCKS
INITIALLY SURFACED OF THIS WAS
HEARD ALL ADDITIONALLY IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND FULL
BUDGET HEARING IT WAS REFERENCED
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARD IT
ALTHOUGH THEY DIDN'T TAKE ACTION?
MARCH TWENTY FIRST I JUST WOULD
BE CLEAR THAT THIS ISSUE HAD
BEEN DISCUSSED WALLY DIDN'T TAKE
ACTION UNTIL TODAY -- I OUR
DUCKS HAD BEEN OUT THERE.
THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME FIRST
TIME HEARING ABOUT IT -- MY READ
MY CONCERNS REMAIN THE SAME OF
THE RELIGIOUS FREEDOM --
CONCERNS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS AND MY APOLOGIES TO MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY CENTER MORLOCK WHO I KNOW
IS NOT CENTER MORALE BECAUSE
HE'S.
THERE'S A QUITE A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT.
WEBSITE THANK YOU.
GOT IT -- SENATOR ROBB AND THEN
BACK TO THIRD OF PANTHERA.
THANK YOU MAYOR RICHARD DID I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS TO MY
COLLEAGUES DO WE KNOW.
WITH RESPECT TO THESE RELIGIOUS
MINISTRIES IF THE IF THE
PARTICIPANTS ACTUALLY FOR
EXAMPLE USE HOSPITALS.
OR IF THAT'S AGAINST THEIR
RELIGIOUS TENANTS IN FACT THEY
PROVIDE THIS HEALTHCARE AMONG
THE COMMUNITY.
SO I WOULD FIRST OF ALL I POINT
OUT THAT -- THIS -- WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET DOES NOT
ACTUALLY BANNER ELIMINATE.
THESE MINISTRIES -- WHAT WE ARE
SAYING IS THAT THE HEALH CARE
MINISTRY DOES NOT COUNT IN TERMS
OF -- MEETING THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE FOR COVERAGE SO SOMEONE
CAN STILL DO IT TAKE THE PENALTY
AND STILL HAVE A HEALTH CARE
MINISTRY RIGHT -- THE OTHER
THING I WOULD POINT OUT I MEAN
THERE VARIETY DIFFERENT ONE SO
YOU ASKING QUESTIONS IT DEPENDS.
IT DEPENDS AND SO AS I MENTIONED
THEY'RE NOT REGULATED THEY DON'T
DOWN THERE ARE CERTAIN RULES IN
PLACE IN THE FIELD FEDERAL
AGENCY ABOUT BUT I MEAN OTHER
WITH THE TERMS OF WHAT TO WRITE
WHAT WOULD BE RECOGNIZED BUT
THEY'RE NOT REGULATED.
AND SO THE CHALLENGE AND I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT ACTUALLY MOST
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY.
USE INSURANCE THEY DON'T USE
HEALTH CARE MINISTRIES THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE INSURANCE THEY
PROVIDE FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES OR
THEIR MINUTES YOU KNOW THAT THE
MEMBERS WHAT AT THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE FOLKS WHO WORK FOR
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THIS IS AND WE'RE NOT
BANNING THEM AT THIS IS NOT THE
MAIN MECHANISM BY WHICH MOST
PEOPLE GET HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
EVEN AND RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I I I THINK THAT -- THIS
IS SIMPLY ABOUT WHAT BEING SURE
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
PEOPLE HAVING COVERAGE THE DATE
WE ARE SURE THAT THEY HAVE FORM
OF COVERAGE THAT MEETS THE
STANDARD ENSURES THAT THEY WILL
HAVE -- THAT THE STANDARDS THAT
WE'VE ESTABLISHED HERE IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA.%
MEDICAL TO CLARIFY JUST ONE
SECOND.
ON THE DOG GO -- TO BACK YOU
MISTER JONES AND THEN YOU SAID A
ROCK BUT TO CLARIFY.
THE ACTIONS BEING FOR POLLS
DON'T THURMOND.
THE HEALTH CARE MINISTRIES -- IT
EXCLUDED EXEMPTS THEM
[inaudible]
FROM [inaudible]
THE MANDATE.
GOT IT ALL RIGHT LET ME GO BACK
TO MISTER JONES AND THEN BACK TO
SIT AROUND I APOLOGIZE A SINNER
UP I THINK I KINDA IS THAT NOT
ESSENTIALLY A BAND.
AND THEN AND THEN THE SALT NOW
BECAUSE THE BAND WOULD SAY THAT
YOU CAN NO LONGER HAVE THE
HEALTH CARE MINISTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD BE A BAND
OKAY THAT WE'RE SAYING IS YOU
YOU CAN STILL HAVE.
BE A MEMBER OF THE HEALTH CARE
MINISTRIES BUT YOU MUST ALSO
ACCORDING TO THE PORTABLE CARE
ACT.
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE WELL WHAT
WE WOULD SAY IS IS THAT
BASICALLY IF IN ORDER.
TO ADD THAT THE TERMS OF A
WHETHER YOU'D BE A PENALTY WOULD
BE APPLIED -- UNDER DATE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE THAT'S IN THE FEDERAL
LAW WE'RE PUTTING A STATE
PENALTY IN ORDER FOR YOU TO SAY
THAT YOU DO NOT.
THAT YOU WILL NOT GET A PENALTY --
AND WE WILL EXCLUDE BEING SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR MEMBER HEALTH
CARE MINISTRIES SO BE A MEMBER
THE HEALTH CARE MINISTRY WOULD
NOT.
QUALIFY IS BEING EXEMPT FROM THE
PENALTY -- THERE'S NOTHING THE
BAND THE MINISTRIES THEY CAN
STILL EXIST -- BUT YOU CAN'T IN
YOUR TAX BY STATE TAX FILING SAY
THAT WELL I WAS A MEMBER
HEALTHCARE MINISTRY THEREFORE I
AM EXEMPTED FROM THE PENALTY -
SO THAT IS THE WITH THAT THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING THAT'S WHY THIS
IS BEING DISCUSSED IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE THIS -- THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PORTION OF
THE THIS BILL SO NOW I'M NOW I'M.
ALERTED TO AN ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGE -- SO I'LL GO BACK TO
SO TWO THINGS BACK TO
UNREGULATED I MEAN I JUST FIND
IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
NO ZERO REGULATIONS.
ON THESE TYPE OF SYSTEMS WHEN
THE ACA RECOGNIZES THEM AS A AS
A PROPER -- MEDICAL COVERAGE
TOOL FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY USE THESE --
BUT I KNOW IT'S A MARKET
RESPONSE TO THE ACA THAT THE ACA
KNOWLEDGES OKAY SO NOW LET'S GO
BACK TO THE THE LAST POINT THE
DOCTOR PAN MADE.
ON THE ON THE TAX RETURNS OKAY
SO NOW WE'VE GOT AS A TOOL
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THE RES OF
THE COUNTRY.
THAT YOU CAN RECOGNIZE ON YOUR
IRS TAX FORMS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
NOW SAYING ON OUR TAX FORMS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO RECOGNIZE IT
AND IT'S NOT.
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIANS -- BUT
ON OUR FEDERAL TAX FORMS IT IS
SO EIGHT AGAIN I JUST GO BACK TO
THE THIS IS THIS IS GOT ALL
KINDS OF PROBLEMS -- AND I'M I'M.
I WILL LET MAKE AS MY FINAL
COMMENT I'M STILL VOTING NO
APPRECIATE THAT BUT JUST A
DEPEND IF YOU WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THERE IS NO LONGER A
FEDERAL MANDATE.
HELLO I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
ACTUALLY.
CONGRESS VOTED.
TO ELIMINATE THE PENALTY ON THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE SO
TECHNICALLY WHAT HAPPENED IS
CONGRESS ACTED IN THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED.
A BILL THAT STILL RETAIN THE
MANDATE ITSELF BUT MADE THE
PENALTY ZERO SO THERE'S NO
PENALTY SO -- SO THERE'S NO SO
IN THIS CASE IF ACTUALLY
INTERESTING ENOUGH -- I THINK
BELIEVE UNDER A TRAILER BILL IF
CONGRESS WOULD RESTORE THE
PENALTY AGAIN AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
WE WOULD NO LONGER HAVE A STEEP
PENALTY AND THE MINISTRY I GUESS
WITH TOWN UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW
BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THERE'S NO REGULATORY BODY THAT
REALLY THERE ARE STANDARDS IN
THE LAW THAT IS NO REGULATORY
BODY THAT OVERSEES -- THESE
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRIES
SENATOR OFF.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- YOU'RE
OUT OF DIFFERENCE TO MY FELLOW --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR WHOSE
FORMER EXPERT IN THESE AREAS AND
I AM.
I'M GOING TO VOTE TO MOVE THIS
UP TO TODAY BUT I I WOULD LIKE
PERSONALLY TO GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
I GUESS WE'D SAY GRANULARITY ON
THIS ISSUE -- AS IT MOVES TO
CONFERENCE -- IS TO THE NUMBER
OF PARTICIPANTS ON THE SINCE IT
HAS APPARENTLY BEEN A CONSIDER
TO BE COVERAGE ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL HOW MANY.
FOLKS ARE COVERED IN THESE
PARTICULAR.
ASSURING MINISTRIES WHAT THE
STATISTICS ARE IN.
AND REALLY WHAT THE IMPACT ON
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
IS IF IF IN FACT.
THERE LARGELY RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS WHO TREAT THEIR
OWN AND DON'T TO DON'T -- TO
BELIEVE IN ATTENDING HOSPITALS
AND AND THE LIKE SO.
I AM GOING TO VOTE FOR TO MOVE
IT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DON'T
WANT TO ASSUME THAT IT WILL BE
IN CONFERENCE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ACTION THE ASSEMBLY TOOK.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION --
WILL MAKE IT CLEAR WHAT THAT IS
THE MOTION IS.
ON ISSUE.
FORTY TWO THANK YOU THE MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE.
PALM AND IT IS DETAILED ON PAGE
FORTY THE AGENDA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL BY
YES AND NO.
L..
DRAGO.
HER TARA [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN.
PAN ALL RIGHT ROTH.
SKINNER FIVE STERN.
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
HI.
WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE FORTY THREE UNDER PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SB NINE OH ONE
CLIMATE CHANGE CALIFORNIA'S.
ENERGY FUTURE.
SO THIS PROPOSAL COMES OUT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S REPORT WILDFIRES
IN CLIMATE CHANGE THAT YOU THE
CHAIR REFERENCED.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PUT OUT
IN APRIL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY IT'S COLLEAGUES HAVE.
ON ISSUE FORTY THREE LA JOH.
ROSS BROWN ABELLIO -- NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MAP ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUE.
FORTY THREE THE IT IS BEEN MOVE
THAT WE APPROVE THE REQUESTED
FUNDS A POSITION FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
FIVE I FOUND [inaudible]
RAZA [inaudible]
TARA [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
A LOT [inaudible]
MORRELL.
PAN.
RIGHT TO THE SPOT.
STERN ALL RIGHT DOWN.
NUMBER.
NINE MY COUNTY I YEAH.
I'D LIKE. TO ACTED.
OKAY SO I STILL HAVE.
GET A HOLD THE ITEM OPEN AT THE
SERGEANTS CAN CALL THE MEMBERS
OFFICES TO SEE IF THEY INTEND TO
RETURN -- SENATORS.
LEYVA -- AND MORRELL.
AND MISTER JONES JONES IS HERE.
WE COULD CALL THOSE MEMBERS SO
FAR I DON'T CALL THE VOTE IF
IT'S STILL HELD OPEN IF YOU WANT
TO KNOW WHAT IT IS OUT SHARE IT
WITH YOU [inaudible]
POSTED [inaudible]
HELLO
COMMITTEE.
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE IN
THESE RESOURCE ISSUES
PARTICULARLY BEEN RELATED TO THE
FIRE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL WORKING WITH THIS.
TOO BUT THE GOVERNOR'S.
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE START AND
THEN AS THE BUDGET WAS SUBMITTED
AND THEN IT IS A PROGRESS
THROUGH -- TO WHERE WE'RE AT
TODAY.
AND THE WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN VERY VERY CONSTRUCTIVE
AND I THINK COUPLE TO ALL OF THE
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
THE FIRE.
IN THE MIND WHICH IS PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT MORE SO THAN OTHERS I
CAN CERTAINLY ATTEST TO THAT.
BUT THIS BEEN ALL HANDS ON DECK
TO DRIVE TO BE OF ASSISTANCE AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE MORE
CHALLENGING TIMES IN HISTORY SO.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
COMMENT NEVER WAITING FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ARRIVE BECAUSE OF
THESE VOTES MISTER -- THIS ONE
OFF AND I I WOULD JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS IN IN IN IF --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DEEMS IT
NECESSARY TO MAKE ANY ACCOUNTING
CHANGES IN ACCORDANCE WITH
RECONCILIATION CONVERSATIONS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF ARE
ENGAGED IN THAT PROCESS.
AS WELL THAT'S NOT THE THAT'S
BEEN OUR PATTERN PRACTICE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES THIS BUDGET CYCLE AS
WELL.
WE WILL BE IN VERY CLOSE TOUCH
TALK WITH JOE ON A DAILY BASIS I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALL AND SO WE ARE WAITING TO
HEAR.
FROM THE SERGEANTS ABOUT THE
INTENTIONS OF MEMBERS TO RETURN.
DO YOU THINK THE REST.
NUMBER EIGHTY IF YOU WERE ON
EVERYTHING YOU INTEND TO VOTE ON
THEN YOU'RE FINE
CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ISSUE.
FORTY TWO WE CAN GET A QUIET IN
THE HEARING ROOM BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE PLEASE.
ISSUE FORTY TWO IF YOU CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA.
MORALE UMBERG.
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK
.
MA'AM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ISSUE FORTY I BELIEVE
WE CAN CALL THAT WITHOUT AS WELL
ISSUE -- FORTY EITC.
AROUND.
NUMBER [inaudible]
HM [inaudible]
CAM [inaudible]
NOT CORD [inaudible] TWELVE
THREE TWELVE THREE THAT ITEM IS
OUT ISSUE FORTY THE VOTE WAS.
TWELVE TO THREE THE MOTION
CARRIES.
WE STILL HAVE ITEMS ISSUE FORTY
ONE FORTY TWO AND FORTY THREE
ALL OPEN.
PERFECT.
BUT WE'RE WAITING FOR THIS LABOR
TO RETURN [inaudible]
WE YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL COULD COULD YOU TELL
ME THE YEAR CURRENT VOTE ON
ISSUE.
FORTY ONE THE CURRENT ACCOUNT IS
TWELVE TO TO PICK UP PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS IN ISSUE
[inaudible]
FORTY ONE MORRELL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO THAT THIRTEEN TO THAT ITEM IS
OUT ISSUE FORTY TWO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA.
HI [inaudible]
BROWN. TWELVE FOR THAT ISSUE
CARE IS OUT ISSUE FORTY THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MARA [inaudible] SEVENTEEN ZERO
THE MEASURE KERRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TODAY'S BUDGET THIS FOR YOU
HEARING STANDS ADJOURNED